you've been walking for days your body
aches you're dripping with sweat from
The Heat Of The Sun bearing down
overhead and yet you're wrapped up in
layers upon layers of clothing even your
face is covered and you're wearing thick
black goggles so that not a single
centimeter of your body is exposed your
journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion or from
overheating due to these multiple layers
of clothes but dying is better than
being exposed you saw it happen when
your entire team changed the lights
cannot be trusted not even for a
fraction of a second it's been like this
for years you've learned and survived
through painful experience many of those
You Used To Know cannot say the same
you've been alone for so long you might
have given up all hope if it wasn't for
the distress signal coming from a nearby
SCP Foundation containment facility site
46 any kind of survivors would be better
than nothing no matter what kind of
sorry shape they were in as long as they
were still human you find your way to an
opening in the side of a mountain and
slide into the cave hoping you weren't
spotted the whole world is crawling with
those things now you can't let yourself
be seen as you trudge down the cave
towards the entrance you see what looks
like a huge black snail Trail splattered
on the ground leading into the facility
you try to avoid it and press on you
don't even need a key card to enter the
door has been left ajar the facility
reeks of those things but you can't see
any of them you just hope they've moved
on and left some human survivors in
their wake the place looks abandoned
every step you take Echoes through the
empty Halls when you find that the
elevator's out you take the stairs all
the way down to level B5 ketter
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the horrors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coup you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedures put into place in a
k-class scenario like this safeguards no
longer apply you can access all the
information you need up to and including
finding out what actually happened in
the dull glow of a nearby emergency
light you see a dark shape slumping
through the halls and Shadow you tense
up then exhale as it slithers off into
an adjoining Hall you're safe for now
the terminal has finally loaded and
authenticated your access you're staring
at the file for SD locks proposal for
scp-001 when day breaks it's the only
name you can give the apocalypse your
world is currently experiencing this is
one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be
given the apollyon containment class
meaning containment is truly impossible
scp-001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
scp-001 and those effects are Beyond
horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to scp-001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is
scp-001-a these new entities are to be
avoided at all costs but in case of
emergencies the administrator says it is
permitted to cut off parts of your
transform comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation no attempt should be made to
kill them since you won't succeed you'll
just put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became scp-001 it instantly
affected 6.8 billion innocent people the
second the visible light touch them
whether it was from the Sun itself or
even reflected off the moon their bodies
liquefied melting like candle wax into
puddles of living gelatinous slime this
effect isn't isolated to humans either
any biological entity exposed to
sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into
scp-001-a and the horror had only just
begun people transformed into
scp-001-a will remain shades of their
Former Intelligence and personality they
may even try to will their new GUI Mass
into a shape resembling their original
form however these individuals will lose
their sense of self if they come into
contact with other instances of
scp-001-a when they come together
001-8 instances will bond on a molecular
level wading up into horrific giant
blobs with only one purpose integrating
more matter into their bodies that's why
they have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the scp-001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan Agata her
partner Ari a security officer named
commander anod and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companions seem to frayed but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have been as
hopeful as drigata led on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted Flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for Mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
Sun Touched his skin in he melted away
and was absorbed by the great Mass
holding him in place guns were
ineffective against these
scp-001-a superentities fire would do no
good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then not
permanently there was one ray of light
in the darkness the site director had a
secret tunnel underneath his office
connected to a tram that could hopefully
take them directly to site 19 without
risk of scp-001 exposure it was a good
plan and by far the best option they had
available to them but the best plans
often don't work in practice you open
the next Detachment on the terminal this
time it's a video feed you can actually
see Dr Logan igata and she looks
harrowed by what she's experienced as it
turns out while the others including her
partner Ari attempted to escape through
the tunnel something had happened Dr
igata heard Ari's voice over her radio
but there was something wrong with it it
was too low too guttural and filled with
gurgles
scp-001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
Escape now seemed gone Ari told Dr igata
that it would be fine that it was such a
bright beautiful sunny day outside and
she was wasting it locked up inside that
office she tormented Dr igado with their
shared memories of picnics in the park
on sunny days in the past the monster
with Ari's voice did everything it could
to try to convince Dr igata to give up
and join them but she wasn't ready to go
just yet you look away from the screen
when you hear a sound in the corner you
see a dark puddle of some unknown
substance and then some skeletal hands
were rising out of it the hands are
pulling themselves out of the puddle
followed by a skeletal face covered in
matted hair you have to stop yourself
from screaming until a flash from a
nearby security light makes the figure
disappear it's a normal puddle once
again Your Mind is Playing Tricks on you
you open the next attachment another
video and see that drigata's condition
has deteriorated she looked pale frantic
and thin she was using a knife to draw
her own blood onto a piece of
blood-stained parchment covered in
strange symbols it got a ranted about
her Theory what if 001 took the minds
and bodies of its victims but not their
souls through performing some kind of
Arcane blood ritual she hoped to at
least rescue and keep the soul of Ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next Detachment it seemed that
agada's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the Twisted soul of Ari driven
mad by scp-001 had taken over the file
it begins corrupting the text of the
scp-001 file into crazy ranting about
how futile it is to fight it then cuts
to an even more frightening video feed
Dr egata in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through Dr igata's hair it's
that exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier you
must have seen Ari's lingering spirit
with a lump in your throat you open the
next attachment and watch the video you
see Dr egata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by Ari's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it is clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes
there's only one way to escape but not
like this she doesn't and want the gun
to draw attention to her body she
doesn't want to become part of that mass
even if she is dead she opens a drawer
on her desk she's recording at and
places the gun inside Dr egata then
apologizes to her loved ones who are
likely long since dead or assimilated
and turns off the recording for the last
time in that moment you realize there's
a single drawer in the desk in front of
you when you reach forward and open it
you see the same handgun Dr igada was
holding is laying inside you pick it up
and study it weighing your options
perhaps there truly is no other way out
then you see an update on the file one
more attachment has been added while you
were studying the gun you feel your
heart pounding in your chest as you
reach forward and open the attachment
the text has been changed entirely the
file on scp-001 is now a poem an Ode to
the Sun and to ultimate togetherness the
then a video file spontaneously opens
itself on the screen it's a video of you
shot from behind you see those oily
skeletal hands reaching for you in the
dark just like they did with Dr egata in
that moment you panic and fire the gun
behind you hoping to scare off the
spirit instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty Halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob ferries you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again it isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic Furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also insanely complicated how
do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities rather than a single object
location or being
scp-001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential
candidates for the prestigious 001 spot
some believe there's a true zero zero
one hidden in this group and the rest
are decoys others think that these are
all just scp's cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the scp-001 throne we're not
here to make a final judgment instead
we're going to take you on a lightning
round crash course through 31 of the
scp-001 proposals if you'd like a more
in-depth take on any of these scps let
us know in the comments but for now the
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chief of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the chief of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this Account Details the
capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr Keeter was
killed inspiring the creation of the
infamous Keeter class in his honor
number 29 the gate Guardian this huge
multi-winged sword wielding biblical
energy being may have been the impetus
for the founding of the SCP Foundation
this being remains largely static
guarding the intersection of the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers its flaming sword
which is believed to be as hot as the
sun can cleave any aggressor out of
existence at the atomic level when the
founder of the SCP Foundation First
encountered the gate Guardian they heard
one word echoing through their mind
prepare and the rest is history number
28 the lock this Onyx gemstone and the
incredibly complex lock attached to it
are still a mystery to this day all
attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshiper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appear gravel pathway that when traveled
clockwise appears completely normal
however when travel counterclockwise the
path goes uphill forever in defiance of
all laws and physics this simple anomaly
opened a Pandora's box of rampant
anomaly creation leading to a number of
the deadly scps we know today number 25
the Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
trans-dimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22. 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keter duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keter-class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scp's breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four
sub-proposals remember what we said
about complicated these sub proposals
include the children nine anomalous kids
who emit radiation and have destructive
potential in together the broken God aka
meccane the god of metal intelligence
and machines atonement a researcher
turned into a humanoid Singularity with
the power to destroy whole realities and
the way it ends which isn't technically
an SCP but the tales of the chaos
insurgency's quest to eliminate all the
members of the foundation's o5 council
number 19 a record this is an SCP file
slot that is itself an SCP whatever is
written into the slot becomes true and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself into a
kind of all-powerful God number 18 past
and future these scps are collection of
powerful entities that despise humanity
and are apparently the source of all
anomalous phenomena even making already
dangerous scps deadlier than before much
like the database those pesky SCP Wiki
writers might have something to do with
this number 17 the consensus this SCP
refers to a reality restructuring event
caused by an occult war in a previous
reality that's right this SCP already
won and we're living in its new reality
the only people who remember the world
as it once was are 13 people who now
form the o5 council and not all of them
are telling the truth about what they
know number 16 when day breaks this
proposal details a potentially
world-ending SCP phenomenon wherein the
sun becomes hostile and begins to melt
all living beings into a living wax-like
substance number 15. God's blind spot
this is an anomalous area referred to as
facility tea in which nobody can die
this anomaly dates back to the biblical
ages of Moses and is believed to have
originated from the literal blessing of
the abrahamic god it's through a
covenant with this God that the
foundation is able to make limited use
of this death-free area number 14
normalcy ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the o5
council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 the
world at law Arch as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another dimension's SCP Foundation
hoping to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12. dead men this SCP was an 84
year old man whose body when damaged and
mutilated can affect the very processes
of human Death At Large before his own
death he was used as a dangerous Pawn in
a civil war between o5 command and the
SCP Foundation Ethics Committee yeah we
were surprised to hear they had an
Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
late number 10. the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extra dimensional
being its worshipers attempted to summon
him in the ritual that created scp-230
one and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of
scp-231-7 you better hope you're already
dead by then number nine a simple toy
maker AKA Dr wondertainment this is a
reality vendor who appears to be a
normal human male but has the ability to
create other anomalous objects a number
of which are now cataloged scps number
eight story of your life this is another
anomalous document that has the ability
to warp reality but only when the
writing contained within conforms to a
narrative structure number seven a good
boy this is another anomalous entity
created accidentally by the foundation
itself a neural network was fed
information on other anomalous entities
in order to help the foundation come up
with better containment and
neutralization procedures problem was
the computer got way way too eager with
the neutralization part number six
project Palisade this is another anomaly
created by the foundation this time to
combat a potentially reality destroying
entity known as the were the foundation
created a number of alternate realities
as Shields but it's possible that this
just made the worm stronger number five
o5-13 the final member of the o5 council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the o5 council are anomalous o513's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number 4.
fishhook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
scp-001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation
station file entry number two the
solution another one of the most
powerful anomalous items in the
foundation's control the solution is
machine designed with the capability of
fully collapsing reality into an event
of end of world SCP Containment Breach
and then finally rebuilding reality to
suit a given narrative however things
took a cosmically dangerous turn when
the machine began to act on its own when
the foundation tried to reboot the
machine it broke and recreated reality
within complete data this is the world
we exist in now with no knowledge of
what came before and how it differed
from the world we experienced today
finally number one the tendulos Trinity
put very simply the tenderloos Trinity
represents three timelines that converge
and feed back in on themselves even
trying to summarize this one is near
impossible as its strangeness and
complexity resists all reduction you can
hunt down the tenderlo's Trinity
yourself and hope to unpack its Secrets
but don't say we didn't warn you so
that's scp-001 is it one of them all of
them or even none of them perhaps that's
a question best left up to the
foundation or maybe the simple answer is
that you're just not meant to know we're
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a memetic
kill agent that'll quite literally make
you drop dead if you view the files
without proper authorization you do have
proper authorization right the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to Pure Evil
whether it's a reptile that wants to end
all life a sadistic old man with his own
torture Dimension or the personification
of death itself lurking Beyond a
limestone Cavern but what if there was
something even worse out there the
embodiment of chaos and cruelty existing
across multiple realities and dimensions
and what if it was coming for us this is
the Scarlet King believed by many to be
the ultimate Evil behind much of the
trouble the foundation has faced and
some even speculate that fight guiding
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the Scarlet King he's known
by many names almost always including
some allusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power
the red Shah the Crimson Khan pte 616
Mendez ex machina the laharaja and of
course
scp-001 to name a few and like many of
the foundation's mysterious enemies
stories about his true nature and
Origins abound and are often
contradictory according to the official
scp-001 files of tufto's proposal
symbology of the Scarlet King has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the King often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities at the SCP
Foundation is familiar with are believed
to be somehow connected to the Scarlet
King including
scp-2317 a wooden door leading to the
realm of a being known as the Devourer
who is expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ketter but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individual tools and anomalies in
our universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
o5 councils so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the Scarlet
King's most recent attempts to enter our
reality
scp-231 this SCP often referred to as
the brides of the Scarlet King was
formed of seven women seven by the way
being an extremely significant number
for the king all kidnapped by the most
recent and a long line of the king's
devote Cults known as the children of
the Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the infamous
scp-682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed the catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Montauk was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly it has six
catastrophes had already occurred Russia
was mounting to figure out a way to
prevent the final birth but as he was
working on the issue Dr Montauk was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his
fourteen-year-old brother Jacob in his
fear and anger Montauk believed that
this must have something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples wanting
Revenge Montauk proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
Montauk to be performed on the final
bride at regular intervals however this
wasn't the end of Dr montauk's front
relationship with the Scarlet King it
was just the beginning to give you some
perspective on just how dangerous the
Scarlet King is the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition decided to
put aside their differences and form a
joint effort to Stamp Out the children
of the Scarlet King they were successful
in this Mission and even managed to
capture the children's leader a
mysterious man named Depeche Spivak Dr
Montauk who became the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317 was naturally the first
choice for interviewing dipesh about the
true nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Montauk could never be
the impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though
the suspicion that the Scarlet king or
the children had something to do with
the loss of his younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders Depeche was
extremely cryptic and his answers to Dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying Montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals Depeche also revealed that the
Scarlet King is bound by Three Laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling Dr Montauk confused and
frustrated by depech's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old Memoir from a
former member of the children of the
Scarlet King Jack Hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the Scarlet King and his
followers and a group of time traveling
turkmen Warriors from
scp-3838 Hearst saw both sides of the
battle from the perspective of the
children of the Scarlet King their lord
ruled over them from an immense Fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the turkmen the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice in The
Roaring howl of the wind Montauk also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet
king-aligned Cults interestingly some of
them Incorporated the use of carved SCP
Foundation symbols what could this mean
Montauk returned again to Depeche who
finally gave him the truth about the law
of blood this is the law of the Scarlet
King it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like surfs in the Middle Ages persecuted
by and subjected to violence from the
Nobles do the children of the Scarlet
King this sense of holy pain and awe is
the only way to live the alternative is
the law of concrete which means the
Modern Age defined by empty safety and
false Comfort buildings easy to access
food Health Care knowledge technology
this is everything that the Scarlet King
despises but the mystery only deepened
as Montauk found files from a former
Foundation operative by the name of
agent dibuvoir Montauk learned that the
Scarlet King didn't seem to appear until
after the foundation was created and in
fact it seemed that the greater interest
the foundation took in The Scarlet King
the more powerful he became how could
this be things were also getting
stranger on a personal level for Dr
Montauk Depeche repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the Montauk procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
montauk's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Danae Cartwright who said we must
learn what it is to die to be enslaved
truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
and darkness The Tempest tossed Refuge
of a race of fools we must kill
modernity post-modernity with all its
analysis and sneering observation there
is only one rule the rule of chaos for
Humanity for life for the Scarlet King
basically anytime Humanity tries to
exert control over the world the Scarlet
King gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining real lies that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of Depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and Depeche demanded a final interview
with Montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation Depeche congratulated
Montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the Scarlet King
dipesh told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
Scarlet King's endless rage at the
direction the world and human entity has
taken the king according to the pesh
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than Petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet Kings realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Montauk his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depash told
him the answer no and in response
Montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the Scarlet
King in light of his new Revel relations
Montauk bagged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the thread posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
Montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation was going on as
normal Montauk grew to despise them he
knew the Scarlet King was coming he knew
that he couldn't be stopped and that our
whole reality was little more than
sitting ducks Dr Robert Montauk is no
longer a researcher for the SCP
Foundation now now Dr Robert Montauk
chose a different path he's now a child
of the Scarlet King a devotee of Madness
hate and Chaos you can't beat the
Scarlet king after all and as the old
adage goes if you can't beat him join
them if you've ever read the book of
Genesis which is the part of the Old
Testament that details God creating the
world and Humanity during a particularly
busy week then you might just be already
familiar with
scp-001 or at least one of the anomalies
that's been proposed for the title of
scp-001 because of course
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation anomaly
sharing the name as cp001 include the
infamous Scarlet King a powerful
Eldritch being intent on ending all of
creation that is thought by Foundation
researchers to be one of the most
dangerous beings in this and any other
universe but the Scarlet King isn't the
only incredibly powerful being
categorized as
scp-001 in fact there are plenty of
other anomalies with similar levels of
destructive power and one such being is
a creature code named the gate Guardian
standing at well over a thousand feet
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these
scp-001 has historically been seen to
have any number of wings between 2 and
108 sprouting from various places over
its body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as
scp-001-2 this weapon resembles an
enormous knife or board capable of
emitting plumes of flame according to
tests conducted by the foundation the
temperature of the Flames produced by
scp-001 rival that of our very own Sun
for reference the sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million degrees
Fahrenheit and
5778 kelvin at its surface or almost 10
000 degrees Fahrenheit you would expect
a flaming sword that burns hotter than
the sun to cause a considerable amount
of damage even if it wasn't in use but
the Flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that Strays too
close to
scp-001 burning them so intensely that
their atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is equally tall as scp-001
itself behind the guardian is a lush
Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to
scp-001 this Grove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit fruit is thought to
be the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of
scp-001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanosecond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at scp-001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to subatomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it regard
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving scp-001
on December 26 2004 an SCP Foundation
nuclear submarine called Nautilus
launched a series of multi-warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
depths of approximately 35 000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35 000 victims families
friends and other related individuals in
order to avoid questioning the SCP
Foundation administered amnestics on an
almost worldwide scale and the o5
council banned any further tests on
scp-001 that evolved nuclear weapons in
what was hoped by the foundation to be a
test with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards
scp-001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thousand foot tall
entity with a flaming sword to tell them
twice the researchers running the
experiment were not swayed by the
request and ordered the d-class to
continue moving towards
scp-001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as is standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d-class
scp-001 appeared not to like this for
some reason though and the researchers
site as well as the researchers
themselves were immediately obliterated
by an unknown Force though it's a pretty
safe guess that a certain flaming weapon
was responsible this candidate for
scp-001 may be one of if not the most
powerful being that the SCP Foundation
has ever encountered and according to
its entry in the scp-001 file the
guardian is even responsible for the
creation of the foundation Nation itself
if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the SCP Foundation One
Day heard a word echoing through his
head prepare this one word instruction
led him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via a telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to scp-001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore These
Warnings though and scp-001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
scp-682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hard to destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt scp-682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment
scp-682 is also one of the few creatures
the foundation actively wants to
terminate a task made that much harder
given that 682 can regenerate its entire
form from as little as a single sell the
gate Guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of
massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation hope to
harness that power to rid the world of
scp-682 for good 682 was placed on an
unmanned vehicle and carried to within
one kilometer of the gate Guardian the
guardian attacked the vehicle seriously
wounding but not killing 682 it seemed
even the mighty
scp-001 couldn't kill the hard to
destroy reptile while the researchers
were disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
Uriel but a pretender Uriel is the
Archangel that some religious texts
describe as the guardian standing at the
Gate of Eden with a fiery sword so does
this mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding is in
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both scp-001 and
scp-073 the anomaly otherwise known as
Kane Kane is a male humanoid of possible
Arabic descent whose arms legs spine and
shoulders are replaced in almost
cyborglike fashion with beryllium bronze
much like the gate Guardian
scp-073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the Bible's Book of Genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother Abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions Kane
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrongdoing in the case of scp-073 any
damage inflicted on him is deflected
back to the attacker but Kane is made to
feel the pain of the attack any plants
or plant-based matter Withers and rots
in his presence and he is cursed with a
perfect memory keeping him forever
haunted by his murder of Abel when Kane
was brought before the gate Guardian an
unknown incident occurred the
foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on
scp-001 the encounter left scp-073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
o5 council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind work to be
conducted on scp-001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that scp-001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other scps of course perhaps it wasn't
just the mistakes of the past that made
the council decide that scp-001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site-0 by
Foundation Personnel detailing an XK
Class end of the world scenario in the
trans transmission the sender believed
to be another member of the SCP
Foundation described an event during
which the gate Guardian finally left its
post stepping away from the entrance to
the Garden of Eden
scp-001 has left its location the sender
wrote the gate is open they are riding
forth oh God it's so beautiful the
transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and hero Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
God deems a time his Angelic armies will
lay waste to the Earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp001 the gate Guardian will open the
gate he stands in front of allowing the
other beings like it to emerge into our
world ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by Personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a timestamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate Guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to Eden waiting the
desert is still the night seems endless
silent and at peace until it's pierced
by the sound of gunshots and screams
deep in the Sahara the SCP Foundation is
Waging War against a newly discovered
enemy a squad of foundation agents is
retreating trying to get away from the
ones who massacred their allies they
were attempting to eliminate the threat
using conventional means but their
rifles were no match for the reality
bending entities of the kingdom of
Abaddon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of Abaddon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their superiors
out of the hundreds of Agents sent into
the Sahara that night only a handful
make it out alive they are debriefed by
their superiors at the foundation who
classified the anomalous humanoids under
the highest of threat levels the kingdom
of Abaddon is a threat the kingdom of
Abaddon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the Abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 Foundation personnel and
had stolen at least 12 different items
from the foundation the leaders of the
SCP Foundation tasked research team
omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the
kingdom of Abaddon once and for all the
weapon they are researching must be
capable of long-range destruction
because the moment any foundation agent
gets close to the area they are
vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants the project is
given the name twins of God and is led
by a foundation doctor known only by the
designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and o51 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of Abaddon item 001
and so the omega-5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item 001
entity and set up a series of
experiments using different people to
harness its energy the first series of
tests all end in tragedy the anomaly
causes the entity it inhabits to become
intensely radioactive anyone who gets
close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness and eventually death
to stop the radiation problems the
omega-5 research group intensifies the
containment procedures o51 receives
reports from the higher-ups that the
kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan long-range
defense is needed ASAP the administrator
puts more pressure on omega-5 and
especially its leader 051 to solve the
problems of item 001 and develop a
weapon that can save the foundation he
stays awake for days on end working
tirelessly to create a safe and
controllable item-001 entity although
there are signs that the weapon will
work it is still unpredictable when
item-001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hemorrhaging and soon a new
host is needed before testing Can Begin
Again and that's not the only thing that
goes wrong
whenever the anomaly is put into a new
host sudden and random destruction of
on-site structures and Personnel take
place o51 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of Abaddon once and for
all in order to control item 001 o51 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains o51 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mine kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the
omega-5 team but progress continues to
be made and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item 001 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but o51 and the omega-5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning
omega-5 along with support from a squad
of armed SCP agents Storm Into the San
Marcos de la Vida sterna Church during
the middle of mass they gather up a
number of the younger congregants and
bring them back to the site where item
001 is housed
the researchers quickly ran through
their new supply of test subjects though
and omega-5 would need to get even more
if their research was to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 001 and omega-5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco
omega-5 makes its most substantial
progress yet just as they theorized by
spreading out the anomaly of item 001
across a specific group of hosts that
can control its powers the test may have
cost the lives of almost everyone in the
town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of Abaddon poses an
existential threat to the SCP Foundation
after all and thanks to This research
they will soon have a weapon capable of
bringing them Victory the foundation
administer criticized o51's methods but
can't argue with his results
unfortunately 051 has a dark secret a
secret that disturbs even the most
hardened and loyal members of omega-5 a
secret that has to do with the item 001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with are not the ordinary
test subjects normally used by the
foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mind that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of omega-5 are haunted
by the screens of the children that they
force to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item 001 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of omega-5 regret what they
have been a part of and they've done all
except 051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that omega-5 hypothesizes
comes from an extra dimensional source
which is used to unbind atoms at the
quantum level when the right activation
words are spoken it appears as though
this tremendous power gives the children
the ability to annihilate anything in
the entire universe it's a gun to end
all guns and only o51 has the key to
control it the nine children work so
well with an item 001 that omega-5
reclassifies it to include the nine
children themselves they are not just
the entity housing or controlling item
001 they permanently become item 001
once omega-5 has a better understanding
of item 001 they begin to run tests to
find out the full extent of its
abilities first they test the distance
item 001 can reach the initial test that
Omega 5 carries out is on a steel rod
placed five kilometers away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to o51
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer tasked with watching the pole
is on the other end the informs051 that
the steel rod has been completely
vaporized o51 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8 000 kilometers away from the
nine children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized
oh five one Smiles the next series of
tests omega-5 runs on item 001 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed the tests start
out with a steel sphere three meters in
diameter placed one thousand kilometers
from item 001 051 orders the children to
destroy the object it is instantly
vaporized o51 has seen enough small
tests in time for something big so he
does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
001 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area deadly and precise 051 closes his
eyes and takes a deep breath he looks as
if he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the children and Whispers the name of
someone later that day 051 finds out
that the target he had named has been
vaporized the success of omega-5 and
item 001 is relayed to the
administration of the foundation they
are so impressed that they make plans to
use item 001 to eliminate the Abaddon
threat once and for all however one of
the heads of the foundation
administrator Williams has major
concerns about the way o51 is running
the program the updates that o51 has
been sending have become less scientific
philosophical more spiritual
administrator William sends a letter to
051 reassuring him that he is doing good
work but once the mission to destroy the
kingdom of avadon is completed 051 will
be promoted to director and reassigned
to the newly constructed site-19 for the
good of the foundation and maybe the
rest of the world he'll be permanently
moved away from item 001 o51's response
is short and to the point I am fine
administrator the project is finished we
will complete our task when you arrive
administrator Williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later he is greeted
by o51 and the omega-5 team Williams
can't help but notice that o51 has a
strange look in his eyes it is the look
of a crazed man who has been lost in his
work and who has perhaps lost himself
Williams puts the thought away though
and walks with 051 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item 001 will be demonstrated
administrator Williams and the other
agents watch from a protected viewing
room as o51 enters the Chamber of his
new super weapon it's time to see if
their weapon that has had so much time
effort sweat tears and especially blood
poured into it will have been worth it
everyone watches as 051 leans over and
says the name of the Abaddon Citadel to
the nine children all at once they start
to Glow no one observing can see what
has happened in the far-off Kingdom but
they know something big has happened the
administrator is thrilled but notices
something
051 hesitated the moment while leaning
over the children before standing back
up
do you whisper something else to them
and then administrator Williams
vaporizes pulled apart at an atomic
level before he has the chance to scream
what's going on the agent standing next
to where administrator Williams
previously existed began to yell and
pull out their guns they burst through
the door of the observation room and run
down the hallway towards where 051 and
the nine children are located the arm
agents rush into the room but o51 is
gone
nine children are still over the next
few weeks 051 is reported to be seen
several times by SCP agents however no
one is able to catch him and it appears
as though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone AWOL as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of Abaddon
but even with this Victory the highest
levels of the SCP Foundation have an
ominous thought lurking in the back of
their minds where did o51 go and what is
he planning to do next
following the improper use of item 001
leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member
the weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to emit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags and
buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the Church of San Marcos de la
Vida Eterna
though all the children continued to be
functionally brain dead they still
displaced Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a
formula entity the smell of fire and oil
fills the air the sound of gears
grinding can be heard between the
explosions and shrieks of Terror a man
runs out of his house only to have his
leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door
scp-001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical Parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron chains swing from its form cast
iron gears whirl within it a glowing
light throbs from the center of its body
scp-001 is consuming everything in its
path after incorporating the truck
chassis into its being
scp-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion to
the next house it rips the gutters from
the side of the building residents who
live in the air area flee their
neighborhood all the while hoping that
the mechanical monstrosity skips over
their house so they have something to
return to if they make it out alive a
section of scp-001's undercarriage drops
away from the main body it rolls down
the street consuming more and more
material the new entity resembles a
human spine and rib cage it topples over
unable to support itself the rib-like
formations extend out to grab anything
and everything within reach the newly
Incorporated material forms what can
only be described as a head light from
within the eye sockets fixate on nearby
civilians the metallic creature picks up
the people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage then it turns and
spots a woman helplessly trying to crawl
away the creature reaches out with a
spiked tentacle and wraps it around the
woman's body she is placed inside of the
chest cavity moments later a severed
hand falls out of the entity and onto
the ground the mechanical monster
continues to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as
scp-001 the Foundation had been in
contact with the Allied occult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worshiped the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the U.S border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside La Paz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La Machina the machine
the commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards La Paz
disappearing Over the Horizon as the sun
sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance they stay
awake all night remaining Vigilant
waiting for the exploratory Squad but
morning
without anyone returning three days
later the foundation Force still has not
seen anything since the exploratory
Squad left then as the sun sits lazily
in the morning Sky a lone figure is
spotted walking down the tracks towards
the trains one of the agents on watch
blows his whistle and points to the
figure a squad of Agents rushes towards
the shadow of a man their guns are
raised ready for anything the figure
drops to the ground and begins to crawl
along the tracks the agents reach the
Fallen man only to find that he is one
of their squad mates who has been sent
up the tracks to investigate La Paz
several days before the agent's name is
DeMarco he is covered in blood his
clothes are in tatters and he has lost a
boot DeMarco lies on his back with
Foundation agents standing around him
his eyes are wide and wild he keeps
babbling on about a world eater how the
rest of his Squad had been mulched and
he is the only one who made it out alive
the foundation agents carry DeMarco back
to the makeshift base they created by
the trains they need to figure out a way
to get the Convoy moving again but
whatever is up ahead has already taken
out an entire Foundation Squad it had to
be something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards La Paz
they start loading their rifles and
check the amount of ammunition and
explosives available in case the
containment process gets out of hand
just as they are about to leave the base
a convoy appears on the horizon it is an
Allied occult initiative Force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is
devastating La Paz this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied
occult initiative may be the only way to
stop what is now known as
scp-001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for La
Paz and what they find causes them to
Quake with fear
scp-001 has consumed so much material it
is the size of a mountain it moves like
like a tidal wave of mechanical
destruction washing over the buildings
and Landscape under it whatever scp-001
passes over is consumed and added to its
massive body
scp-001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine the Church
of the broken God has finally met their
maker as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its
members their God is an all-consuming
monster the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop scp-001 from
continuing its reign of Destruction they
fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical
anomaly they bring in air support to try
and damage it from the skies but nothing
works the aoi uses an artifact in their
possession to lure scp-001 to the coast
of the Pacific Ocean where a trap has
been set for the so-called God the
Monstrous mechanical creature moves
slowly towards the water it consumes
abandoned cars buildings and boats as it
approaches the coastline it even shovels
large amounts of Earth into its form
causing Flames to spurt out from its
inner workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky Airaid Sirens
can be heard in the distance the
enormous Cloud begins to pulsate streaks
of lightning shoot through the Red Mist
in the sky it now sits directly over
scp-001 from within the cloud part of a
ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its Hull the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as
scp-2399 the underside of the vessel
begins to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam
of light is ejected from
scp-2399 which penetrates straight down
and through
scp-001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if
scp-001 is trying to reach up and grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before scp-001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light
scp-2399 blinks out of existence the
sound of grinding gears can be heard
coming from within
scp-001 it begins to shed its outer
layers of metal then the entire
structure that was
scp-001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the Foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of scp-001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized
scp-001 hundreds of anomalous artifacts
are collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of scp-001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection ordeal with their
arms and legs still attached to their
bodies dive teams are sent into the
water to recover parts that have sunk to
the Bottom of the Sea one of the divers
is a local from the area he is hired to
bring up the heart of the machine since
he is an experienced diver used to free
diving to Great depths to collect
oysters from the bottom of the bay the
diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths he secures straps
around the heart of scp-001 and pulls
hard on the Rope as an indication to the
surface that it is ready to be hauled up
the Salvage team on the surface begins
to pull there is a second slight tug on
the Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of scp-001 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the hardest kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of
scp-001 doesn't make it to the
foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area joined the
new religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
Pietra Cal fontained spatial
stabilization array is housed a skeleton
crew is working over overnight to ensure
the array is ready for its big test the
following day the foundation has been
working on a particle accelerator that
will contain anomalies with the ability
to manipulate the nature of space-time
the preliminary tests seem promising but
a few last-minute tweaks to the array
are necessary unfortunately it is on
this night in 1982 that marks the
beginning of the end for the SCP
Foundation Dr Kelvin Desmond is
monitoring the array and he notices as
it spools up that there are some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin Desmond
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Cal of investment grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the Chamber is sealed deep in the
bells of the array Calvin Desmond cannot
hear the evacuation announcement the
humming of the array Echoes through the
chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while Desmond continues to work
on the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmond a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the side of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
Desmond stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin Desmond
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
ripped the main structure away water
flows into the deep hole carved out of
the Earth where the array once stood the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapsed Singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they order the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netzac is put in charge of overseeing
its functions it is a supercomputer that
is program program to follow commands
but can autonomously make decisions in
order to prevent any failures in the
system experiments Begin Again in May of
2006. the new array soon manifests its
first singularity in the containment
chamber at Area 11 and what happens next
will forever change the foundation and
the Multiverse The Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularities growth slows
and then stops netsack has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radio
active gas and dust obscuring the
singularity within as Foundation
scientists work rapidly to fix the array
odd events begin to occur the workers
hear noises that sound like painful
wailing over time the noises evolve into
words and then full sentences they seem
to be originating from The Singularity
using equipment able to penetrate the
thick cloud of radioactive gas the
foundation scientists get a glimpse at
the singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pull of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create soundly
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the array's Rings and says Johannes
Ramsay Dr Ramsay steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
Desmond it is not Desmond per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but it was somehow
created by the accident that had sucked
Calvin Desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of Desmond and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The Desmond
entity asks for an overseer from the
foundation to be brought in it has a
proposal for the o5 council when Dr
Ramsey asks why the entity needs to talk
to the overseers it replies that it
wants to offer them away oh the
following day o51 enters the facility
and heads to the observation deck he
looks through the reinforced glass us at
the swirling cloud of radioactive dust
then glances at the monitor to see the
humanoid shape of the singularity within
he presses the microphone button on the
console and addresses The Entity to whom
am I speaking he asks for simplicity's
sake The Entity tells 05-1 to refer to
him as Calvin Desmond 05-1 makes notes
of the events unfolding before him and
then asks about the way out that Calvin
had mentioned the air is still for a
moment then Desmond begins to speak
through the vibration of the structure
once again he informs o5-1 that what the
SCP Foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound Desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems 05-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities the The
Entity that is Calvin Desmond tells 05-1
that he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from the
confines of the array 05-1 is transfixed
by the swirling gas that is promising
him and everyone else on Earth salvation
he shakes his head in disbelief could
this be true 05-1 turns away from the
swirling gas and begins to walk away
from the viewing glass I'll need to
think about what you're saying the
structure begins to shake slightly the
voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates off
of the array a little louder than before
choose quickly overseer although it
won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibration slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as 05-1 walks out the
next day all staff members located at
Area 11 are relocated to other
Foundation sites and given amnestics the
o5 council meets in a large circular
room with wood paneling and no windows
o5-1 Begins the meeting by telling the
others what Calvin Desmond had described
about the end of the world he pauses for
what seems like an eternity and tells
them of desmet's offer that he could
prevent the end of the world but at the
cost of destroying an infinite number of
other realities this would mean that all
the humans and creatures of those
realities would be destroyed as well was
murdering countless other beings worth
it to protect their own reality 05-1
begins to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmond
he's being torn apart from the inside
05-3 stands up and addresses the council
he informs everyone in the room that
independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities 05-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 05-1
continues to Shake while 05-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vote there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of the realities
and fornays against the plan 05-3 stands
up and walks around the room stopping
behind each nay voter and putting a
bullet in their head he stops at the
last 05-9 who pulls out a gun places it
under her own shin and pulls the trigger
05-13 abstains from the vote and the
measure
the remaining overseers will use the
Calvin Desmond entity to save their
reality at the expense of all others and
they soon head to Area 11 to execute
their plan 05-1 4 and 12 enter the
observation room that looks upon the
swirling radioactive gas around Calvin
Desmond 05-1 orders netsack to begin
powering down the array which will allow
the entity to prove he can do what he
has promised they have pinpointed the
reality that scp-884 came from and the
Shaving mirror itself sits on a table in
another room in the facility 05-3 stands
in the room watching the mirror to see
if anything happens 05-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to eliminate the reality that
the mirror had come from the room Shakes
as the entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 05-3 he
informs the others that the mirror has
disappeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer is
there is a sigh of relief in the room as
the overseers realize that this just
might work 05-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
continue and destroy all the realities
that are bleeding into their own this
time the entire facility begins to Quake
suddenly 05-1 jerks backwards his eyes
wide in confusion and horror his body
seems to be compressing under an unknown
Force 05-1 begins to distort his legs
and arms fold into the core of his body
his head snaps down and all that was
o5-1 is sucked down into a single point
in space before it completely disappears
Calvin Desmond then turns his attention
to the other two overseers in the room
who both seem to collapse into black
holes of their own in the center of
their bodies netsax warning claxen
begins to sound signaling that the
emergency Fail-Safe has been activated
before Calvin Desmond is brought under
control the structural support in the
entire facility vibrates with his words
they are in a voice that sounds strange
similar to o5 ones your children are
free to live lives that do not end in
horror an end to your Perpetual struggle
an end to Darkness the freedom to live
in the light all traces must be removed
this world must be washed clean the
foundation does not Escape atonement it
is the only way out it had been a
deception the Calvin Desmond entity had
no intention of stopping anomalies from
infiltrating this world it wanted to
remove all traces of the anomalous from
all universes including this one and
that meant destroying the overseers and
the foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrificed themselves
and and the foundation even if it meant
an end to the anomalies plaguing our
world now though with the overseers out
of the way the Calvin Desmond entity is
free to move forward with its plan and
Purge all realities of any trace of the
anomalous but just then netsax failsafes
kick in and the petracow fountain
spatial stabilization array subdues the
entity's abilities Desmet is once again
contained 05-3 burst through the door
and into the observation room he stands
before the shattered glass of the window
that looks into the array 053 asks
netsack how long the containment array
can hold Calvin Desmet the computer's
voice fades in and out but says given
current conditions
119 days six hours and 47 minutes
05-3 size he tells netsak to make a node
in the SCP database that the Calvin
Desmond entity will now be known as
scp-001 then to to make dozens of other
randomly generated entries and label
them as
scp-001 as well he knows that they will
need to keep the true nature of what
this entity can do with secret 05-3
walks out of the room under his breath
he speaks to himself they'll say that
I'll know the one true God when I see it
and to give that God everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucian stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sits several hidden figures the
warehouse is falling apart but is
suitable for the meeting Calvin as
requested with the heads of the chaos
Insurgency he has completed numerous
missions for the organization and each
one has been successful now he is
proposing one final mission Calvin
Lucien takes a tattered Journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figure sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 Foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they have been meddling with
reality the business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are Immortal Calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a Silence from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a a
deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucian gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out of the line but the
team is loyal they set out to confront
the 13th overseer this has to be their
first stop because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all the foundation
overseers from dying if that deal can be
broken then Calvin Lucien and his team
will have a shot at eradicating the
other overseers if the deal with death
cannot be broken All Is Lost the team
boards a shift at the tip of South
America and sails towards the Frozen
Waters of Antarctica the kill Squad is
made up of Calvin and three others they
sit in the galley preparing for the
mission ahead Anthony Wright is a
battle-hardened soldier who sits at one
end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crest of the wave the hull is impaled on
the Rocks surrounding the tower sending
everything flowing towards the front of
the boat see that wasn't so bad Calvin
says to his team as he bandages a gash
on his hand knowing what lays ahead
Calvin orders his team to wait on the
ship while he makes his own deal with
death he enters the dark structure and
is greeted by a corpse the corpse speaks
to him ejecting dust from its lungs with
every word its breath smells like
decaying flesh death has inhabited the
body of Dr Felix Carter the 13th
overseer Calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by the neck tilts the head back and
pours liquid down what is left of the
throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living Dr Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseers deal
with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
to the side looking at Calvin so it is
you who has broken the overseers deal
with me Calvin Lucian Calvin takes a
step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something Fester is
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that perhaps if I had a seat at their
table I could find it make it die but I
couldn't there are things in this world
Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucian with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill Squad contacts the Insurgency for
an Evac and then makes their way to
Japan where 05-12 also known as the
accountant has been working out of Tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
to kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot at him but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his assailant's actions
and runs away unable to predict exactly
what they are planning to do the
accountant climbs the stairs to a subway
station and Boards the last car of the
train it is empty except for one man
Calvin Lucian the accountant is
dumbfounded how are you here he screams
I should have seen this coming Calvin
stands up he uses his thumb to flip a
coin into the air on the way down he
grabs it and smacks it on the back of
his opposing hand Calvin Smiles the team
has been making their decisions based on
the flip of a coin which introduced
Randomness into their actions that even
this super Advanced mathematician could
not account for tell me where 05-11 is
demands Calvin the accountant pauses
then shakes his head no if he's going to
die either way then why give any
information to the kill Squad Calvin
flips the coin up in the air catches it
and looks at it the coin is face up
Calvin lifts his pistol and shoots the
accountant in the head a few nights
later Olivia stands on a balcony outside
of an Art Exhibit overlooking the city
of Seattle Anthony walks up behind her
and tells her that the foundation is
defeated but Olivia doesn't understand
how we broke the overseers deal with
death and killed the accountant there's
nothing more to do we can go back to our
normal lives he tells her Olivia is
skeptical though what about the 11th
overseer and his ability to Olivia's
eyes suddenly go wide she pulls out a
knife and stabs it into Anthony's Heart
the world around her begins to distort
and fall apart it was a false reality
created by 05-11 better known as the
liar Olivia wakes up next to Adam in a
hotel room she sits up in a bed and rubs
her eyes what a weird dream she thinks
then she realizes it wasn't a dream she
shakes at him away neither of them have
any idea how they ended up here but they
know it must be the doing of the liar
they had planned for this though with
Calvin having created a contingency plan
they pull out a laptop and log in to
view the classified information Calvin
left for them Olivia begins to type but
stops halfway through her password and
looks up from the screen Olivia pulls
out the gun that rests under her pillow
and shoots at him the false reality
created by the liar falls apart around
her Olivia comes out of the previous lie
and is sitting across the table from
Calvin she immediately draws her pistol
and points it at Calvin's head is it
really him or just another one of the
Liars games Calvin tries to talk Olivia
down and she looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam Beal he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she's free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from a hospital room as Olivia's in the
hospital Calvin and Adam walk through a
dense forest they are searching for
05-10 the journal indicates that the
10th overseer's identity within the
foundation is the archivist in the
middle of the clearing are two saplings
standing side by side the void between
the sapling shimmers Calvin walks
through the portal and the space begins
to warp and twist around him his vision
finally comes back into focus and Calvin
finds himself in another world
Adam enters the World Behind Calvin
practically knocking him over as he
enters through the portal this is The
Wanderers library but it doesn't look
anything like they expected instead of
rows of books the library is filled with
computer mainframes humming with the
collected knowledge of how to contain
anomalies a critical backup
as the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight Emerald
tint it is one of the Librarians Calvin
tells the librarian that they are
seeking the archivist but the librarian
tells them that the archivist is no
longer in the library she has broken her
pact with the serpent and eaten fruit
from The Forbidden trees if they want to
see her though the librarian can take
them to her
Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge eventually they reached the
bottom of the stairs where there stands
a giant set of brass doors Beyond the
Door the librarian explains is the
source of all knowledge before Calvin
and Adam pass through the doors though
Calvin turns to the librarian before we
go in I'd like to make a withdrawal he
says the librarian nods and pulls out a
silver tube out of its row it hands the
tube to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished the door
then opens and the two-step through
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walk
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush Green
Valley with two trees sitting underneath
one of them is a woman in a white dress
she is reading a book and eating a piece
of fruit are you the archivist Calvin
asks the woman nods yes and that's all
the confirmation Calvin needs he raises
his pistol and fires but the bullet
passes right through the archivist as if
she wasn't there
do you read the archivist asks Calvin
seemingly not phased by his attempts to
shoot her I haven't had much time
recently Calvin replied the archivist
explains that she's read every book in
the library the collected knowledge of
the universe is in the books even one on
how to allow bullets to pass through
your body she came here to find the
secret to immortality it's her job to
document everything that happens in the
world and she can't do that if she's
dead she explains that she figured out
that the fruit that the serpent forbade
everyone to eat was an actual fruit but
the knowledge contained in the library
by having read every book she has
consumed the fruit she no longer needs
the serpent because she was the serpent
the archivist falls to the ground and
begins to ride around contorting her
body as it starts to change she begins
to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear the next thing Calvin and Adam
know their face to face with a giant
snake Calvin Dodges as the serpent
lunges at him and Adam stands in the
doorway firing at the snake with his
pistol but just like with the archivists
human form the bullets have no effect
the serpent coils around Calvin and
begins to choke the life from him as
Adam can only watch helpless
Calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube Adam
takes the tube that was given to him by
the librarian and opens the cap a long
heavy spear slides out that looks much
too large to have ever fit inside he
drops the tube to the ground and watches
in amazement as it starts to transform
turning into what looks like a large
Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do and
places the giant spear into the gun and
points it at the serpent you can't kill
me the giant snake sense I've eaten from
the Tree of Life Adam pulls the trigger
and the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head Adam
runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archivist once again pinned against
the tree she once sat under the spear
sticking out of her skull
as the two stand looking at the
archivist a tall hooded humanoid figure
steps out from behind the tree it looks
similar to The Librarian except its robe
is a greenish color and it wears long
black gloves the creature pulls the
spear out of the archivist whose body
slumps to the ground and hands the spear
to Calvin who are you Calvin asks but
his question is ignored after a moment
the figure finally speaks that spear
you'll now hold is called the Spear of
the non-believer it is an ancient weapon
used to kill Gods it is odd that someone
in this realm gave you the spear even
with it I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucian but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered The Wanderers
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony track down 05-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home the journal had listed
this as her address but Calvin doubted
that she would be here and most he hoped
to find a clue to her whereabouts but
here she was sitting in the ashes of her
home without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asked
Calvin if he's afraid of death Calvin
shakes his head and responds Now The
Outsider slumps forward and Calvin walks
around to face her she is covered in
blood her eyes move to look up at Calvin
you're lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05-9 off the list and head back to
the car as they walk Anthony says what's
been on everyone's Minds the last few
days the easy part is done will only get
harder from here we know 05-8 is in his
castle and I'm sure we'll get in but I'm
not sure if we'll make it out alive I
know replies Calvin but if we're going
to save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission
Calvin Lucin leads the kill squad team
through the mud and freezing rain in
front of them looms The Fortress of
Baron Lehman Hodley the eighth overseer
the team has already been through a lot
from breaking the overseer council's
deal with death by eliminating 05-13 to
using the Spear of the non-believer to
kill the Godlike archivist 05-10 the
hunting of overseers has taken a toll on
the kill Squad 05-12 almost killed Adam
and Olivia was stuck in what seemed like
an endless mind game with 05-11 the
first five overseers were eliminated but
the words that the ninth overseer spoke
to to Calvin Lucien before she died
still run through his mind are you
afraid of death now the kill Squad is
about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of o5-8 though the Fortress was
supposed to be practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of o5-8 all the
same the journal Calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the SCP foundation's powerful o5
Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Lehman Hodley
with his vast wealth holdley funded the
foundation at the start and was
considered the unofficial leader of the
council in its early days with immense
control over the actions of the
organization the kill Squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallways of
the castle as they turn the corner they
are surprised to find the charred
remains of Baron Lehman hodley's
bodyguard it seems that someone or
something has gotten too hardly before
they could the team makes their way to
the main chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still-lit fireplace is 05-8
the kill Squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them Adam walks over to the body
and examines it he quickly realizes that
holdley hasn't been murdered at all he
sees that Baron hoadley's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for Baron hoadley when the
overseers deal with death was broken by
Calvin the modifications to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and crosses 05-8 off their
list on their way out Adam pulls Calvin
aside he has the feeling that Anthony
has have been completely honest with the
rest of the team he had the feeling that
Anthony was hiding something from them
Calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes Anthony for more information
about his past and Anthony reveals that
he's over 100 years old the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin has was not the only one early in
his career with the Insurgency he had
confiscated other vials from a
foundation's site his Squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks Calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain I'm
going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with his plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives Intel
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseer is in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who is
codenamed Green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an all-out War the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin
knows that Anthony can take care of him
self they're too close to their goal to
stop now Calvin slowly opens the front
door of the house they are hiding in and
peers out the coast looks clear so he
signals Olivia and Adam to follow him
before they can step out into the street
a gas canister enters through a cracked
doorway the room fills with sleeping gas
and the team passes out when they are
awake they are tied up in a large room
with marble vaulted ceilings 05-7 is
standing in front of Calvin she smiles
wickedly while holding a knife she
compliments Calvin on what he and his
team have been able to do so far no one
believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have but now she
has an offer for Calvin she points
towards Adam and Olivia and tells Calvin
he must choose one of them to die if he
doesn't she'll kill the leader of the
rioters and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utterscreen have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with a
knife above Adam's head before she can
plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
and someone fires a rocket at the
helicopter the rocket hits the tail of
the aircraft sending it crashing into
the plaza full of rioters below as the
crowd flees from the sea Calvin makes
his way towards the wreckage and reaches
it at the same time Anthony does Calvin
looks at him smiles and thanks him for
saving his life Anthony smiles back but
before he can say anything a gunshot
rings out and a bullet rips through his
neck Calvin turns to see where it came
from and is horrified to see the burning
body of 05-7 her skin has been charred
black but in her burnt hand she holds a
gun what's left of her lips curl back in
a Sinister grin as she fires again and
hits Anthony in the chest he falls to
the ground coven runs to him and pulls
out his gun to shoot 05-7 but she is
already dead Calvin holds his dying
teammate his blood pours out of his neck
and chest but Calvin can stop this he
pulls out the vial of water from the
fountain no when says Anthony I have
lived long enough thank you my friend I
will see you in whatever lies Beyond
this life Anthony's chess Rises then
Falls it does not rise again Olivia and
Adam Round the Corner to see Calvin
holding the lifeless body of their
teammate tears flowing from his eyes the
team holds a small ceremony and burial
for Anthony but are only halfway through
their mission and can't stop now they
fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 05-6 is
already aware thereafter him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
U.S military at his fingertips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19. the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up an 05-6 steps
out he introduces himself as Rufus King
member of the overseer Council but an
American citizen first and foremost all
he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the non-believer
rumahaza that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archives you give me the spear I will
let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a frown then I suppose my only other
option is to take it from you but not
without giving you a fair chance run
Calvin Lucian run as fast as you can ah
will be coming for you the American
turns and walks towards the container
from site 19 which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them Calvin
Sprints back to the jeep with the other
members of his team as they drive away
they hear a horrible guttural Screech
from whatever was inside the container
after a few moments the Army begins to
pursue them out in front of the military
force is 05-6 writing
scp-682 he is using a black whip to urge
the creature forward and they're gaining
on the kill Squad fast a row of vehicles
pulls up beside the American and
scp-682 then something strange happens a
man appears in front of the oncoming
forces led by the American the the man's
skin bulges and seems to be moving from
within the skin of the man sloughs from
his body the infection that is scp-610
erupts out of him and onto the soldiers
in the nearby Jeep scp-610 begins to
infect and consume everyone around it
suddenly there are thousands of
instances of scp-610 coming from the
Mountainside flooding into the valley
they close in and around the Army and
05-6 the American begins fighting off
the flesh-eating creatures from the back
of scp-682 but he becomes overwhelmed he
can no longer focus on pursuing Calvin
and his team from the back of the Jeep
Olivia pulls out her rifle she aims and
fires the bullet hits the American in
the chest he is flung off the back of
scp-682 and engulfed in the sea of
scp-610 creatures the kill Squad
continues to drive trying to put as much
distance between themselves and the
scp-610 infestation as Paul possible but
then Calvin suddenly Slams on the Brank
standing in front of them is a man in a
black suit and bow tie he introduces
himself as Blackbird the fifth overseer
according to the journal his actual name
is Mortimer J Denning Von krukniker he
stands in front of the jeep with a
menacing grin you have been causing a
lot of trouble he says looking at Calvin
Olivia swings her gun around oh please
my dear that won't help you Von
crockmekar says he pulls out a knife and
stabs himself through the neck he falls
to the ground apparently dead there is a
gust of wind a whiff of ozone and an
identical copy and still very much alive
on crocknicker lands next to his own
dead body see what I mean he says Olivia
lowers her rifle come with me I have
something to show you the Blackbird
beckons seeing no other option Calvin
olivian Adam exit the Jeep and followed
the Blackbird as they walk the World
changes around them the desert mountains
Fade Away into Blackness and find
themselves in the near apocalyptic
London oh it's good to be how the
Blackbird says as they emerge onto a
cobblestone street you cannot stop the
overseas plans however I can give you an
alternative let's see if any of you will
take it in front of each kill Squad
member appears adore they have an
uncontrollable urge to open their
respective door and walk through the
Blackbird stands smiling as he watches
Calvin Olivia and Adam enter each of
their portals Adam enters his door and
looks around he is in Portland his
parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam lock size
with Calvin who Smiles at him the
Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht and
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
Blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice Calvin steps
through his door he is in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time Calvin you would just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be prey you can actually save your
mother from her faith no Calvin screams
this is isn't real the Blackbird
capitals Calvin looks away from the lake
and towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure Calvin walks towards it
the Blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line I was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands Calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside Calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the Blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the
true form of the Blackbird he is a
winged pseudo-avian monstrosity full of
Rage the mysterious hooded figure
directs Calvin to open the tube again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by DR wondertainment and a
white wiffle ball bat Calvin grabs the
fishing line and wraps it around
05-5's lag the Blackbird flies into the
air trying to get away from Calvin but
Calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of scp-455 in
site 19 where scp-682 walks freely in
the dead world of scp-2935 every time
they stop in a new dimension Calvin
takes the opportunity to attack the
blackbird with the bad and it seems that
he is slowly weakening the monster they
finally land at the bottom of a deep
well foundation containment site where
the dark body that is
scp-001 is contained standing in front
of the containment field is Alison Cho
The Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you Christ the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucian The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucian to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king
screams05-5 Allison Charles eyes she
pushes a button on the panel next to her
shutting down the array containing the
dark body out of the cloud of dust
appears
scp-001 a massive black creature who
seemed to absorb all light no stop
shrieks the Blackbird
scp-001 does not move but the room
begins to shake the Blackbird continues
to scream as his body folds in on itself
until he is reduced to a single
superheated point and then blinks out of
existence Allison Chow then reactivates
the containment array ceiling001 away
once again I will return you to your
reality along with your friends says the
black queen but perhaps our path shall
cross again Calvin Lucian there is a
bright flash of light and Calvin finds
himself on a private jet sitting next to
Olivia and Adam they are all shaken but
the Blackbird is dead 05-5 has been
eliminated the three members of the team
sit silently still pondering What Might
Have Been if they stayed in the
alternate realities suddenly the phone
on the plane begins to ring breaking the
silence Calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer he has
contacted Calvin to discuss surrendering
to the Insurgency unfortunately things
do not always go as planned Calvin
Lucian is about to make the most
difficult and dangerous decision of his
life
Aaron Siegel better known to Foundation
members as 05-1
descends into the abyss of a Deep Well
site he exits the elevator and peers
into the optical scanner to unlock the
reinforced door inside the room is
mobile task force tau5 samsara Aaron
Siegel refers to these Immortal cyborg
clones created from the Flesh of a dead
God as his red right hand your mission
is to eliminate the traitor 05-4 and to
find the insurgents who have been
killing the members of the overseer
Council the cyborg stand at attention
now Aaron Siegel screams the soldiers of
the red right hand March out the door to
start their mission Aaron Siegel pauses
for a moment and then slams his fist
against the wall in frustration he has
lost nine overseers to Calvin Lucian and
his kill squad team they have been
somehow overcoming the odds each time
and eliminating each overseer they track
down it wasn't supposed goes to end this
way Aaron Siegel vows to kill them all
Calvin Lucien meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 05-4 the overseer
known as the Ambassador wants to
surrender to the Insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but Calvin
has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same Calvin drops off Adam and
Olivia at an Insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous Mission with 05-5 known as the
Blackbird before leaving though Calvin
meets with an Insurgency agent named
Sylvester Sloan who is going to join him
as support Calvin says goodbye to Adam
and Olivia then leaves with Sloan to
meet The Ambassador in South Africa
after landing at Johannesburg airport
Calvin and Sloan disembark and are led
to a conference room where the
Ambassador sits waiting for them Calvin
and Sloane sit across from 05-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the Ambassador everything
is falling apart I want to offer my
services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from 05-1 is lost his mind Galvin agrees
to the terms and prepares for extraction
but as they get up from the table
gunshots can be heard from down the hall
the ambassador's eyes open wide in
Terror it's too late he whispers Calvin
and Sloan grabbed the Ambassador who is
Frozen in fear and exit the conference
room they make their way towards their
plane but the gunshots are getting
closer Calvin looks over his shoulder to
see some sorrow pursuing them through
the terminal Calvin shoves the
Ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead Calvin and Sloan returned
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the Assassins Calvin and Sloan
pulled the ambassador to his feet and
they burst through an emergency exit
onto the sun-baked tarmac where they
make a Mad Dash for the plane from
behind them a bullet rips through the
chest of Sloan the red right hand has
caught up but Calvin continues to drag
the ambassador to the plane they are
almost there suddenly a metallic child's
Voice blars through the airport's
external speakers the child's voice says
I want Calvin Lucian alive I have
business to settle with him the red
right hand soldiers tackle Calvin and
the ambassador to the ground when they
are just feet away from the plane kill
the traitor the child's voice says and
Calvin can only watch helplessly as the
Ambassador is violently murdered one of
the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face
causing him to black out Calvin awakes
in a dark room he is unsure how much
time has passed the only light in the
room comes from a screen on the wall in
the middle of the screen is a rotating
red SCP Foundation seal a voice from a
speaker speaks hello Calvin Lucian my
name is the kid I am the third overseer
you have killed all my friends and now I
will kill all of yours the door to the
room opens Calvin leans the doorway
there is a long dimly lit hallway the
kid orders him to proceed so they can
meet face to face as Calvin walks the
kids voice Echoes down the hallway there
once was another 05-3 he built
incredible machines even one that could
see into the future but unfortunately
for him he did not have the passion
required to be an overseer that was when
I was born I was chosen by the other
overseers to have my spinal cord severed
in a way that gave me the ability of the
All-Seeing Eye I now watch everything
all of the time I have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding Calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the kid the black queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and reel
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror in
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as maladramigion the red
right hand engages the monster trying to
force it back into its Dimension but the
monster is too powerful it grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
terror in reality as samsara battles the
maladramikion Calvin freeze Olivia and
Adam they make a run for the door but as
they flee one of the walls opens up to
reveal the turret the gun fires and a
bullet hits Olivia directly in the head
killing her instantly no yells Calvin
before Calvin can push Adam out of the
way a second Bull it from the turret
launches itself in Adam's back Calvin
and Adam slide across the floor the kid
in his mechanical suit jumps down from
the platform above I'm going to kill you
now Calvin Lucian he says in his
mechanical voice there is another flash
of light Calvin watches in front of him
as the Spear of the non-believer
manifests itself before his eyes Calvin
grabs the spear and shoves it into the
kid's machine body it easily penetrates
the armor and pins him to the wall
Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton and
tears off the outer plating revealing a
tank full of fluid within which floats a
malformed human fetus as Calvin finally
looks upon the kid's True Form he hears
the sound of mocking mechanical laughter
Calvin breaks the glass and crushes the
kid with his bare hands as Calvin turns
from the now silent robotic body of the
kid the room begins to shame debris
raining down from above Calvin helps
Adam up and puts Olivia's lifeless body
across his shoulders what remains of the
kill Squad makes their way out of the
kid's Lair outside of the foundation
side where they were being held Calvin
helps Adam lie down on the ground before
gently setting Olivia's body next to him
Adam grimaces as blood pours out at the
wound in his back Calvin reaches into
his pocket and pulls out the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth there
are only a couple of drops left which he
pours into Adam's mouth Adam looks up at
Calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers I love you before he passes out
from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and Calvin
calls an Insurgency Evac team to come
pick up Adam with Adam's safe Calvin
picks up Olivia and walks alone towards
a truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 05-1
Aaron Siegel arrives at where the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers meet the garden of
Eden he is in a frenzy due to the
assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron Siegel has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for o5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power Aaron Siegel possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazarene's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
Snowy White Hand it's a no in it the
Nazarene explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
in death always brought brought her back
each time she felt less and less like
herself less and less like Dr Sophia
lined she hoped that maybe if things
ended up like this it would give Aaron
the chance to walk away and live the
life that they might have been able to
have together but she knows deep down
that Aaron's fate is to meet Calvin and
finish things once and for all Aaron
Siegel screams and rage clutching the
node in his hand he tries to summon
death but no one comes Aaron Siegel is
alone he stands up and walks deeper into
the garden he walks until he reaches a
spot where even God's light does not
reach in this desolate land is an impact
crater where Lucifer star of the morning
had fallen in the middle of the crater
lies Lucifer's sword Aaron Siegel
descends into the hole and picks up the
sword he turns and exits the Garden of
Eden Aaron Siegel has only one mission
in life now to kill Calvin Lucian Calvin
reads the final entry of the journal in
it the author warns that although he
hopes the information contained within
the journal is helpful he hopes the
reader does not try to use it the words
written on the final page are this
information will only lead you to a
devastating end Calvin closes the
journal and looks up at the structure in
front of him he has made it to scythe01
he had left Olivia's body in a cave
nearby promising to her that he would
make this right he now walks up to the
massive doors and places his hand on the
knotted one the doors slowly Creak open
Calvin pauses for a moment and looks
behind him at the Setting Sun he enters
site-01 where he knows 05-1 is where
Aaron Siegel Waits inside the main hall
Calvin sees a giant doorway in the shape
of the SCP Foundation seal with artistic
depictions of certain scps that he
instinctively knows are special in some
way standing next to the doorway is a
two meter tall man in what looks to be a
futuristic suit Calvin approaches and
asks who this giant man is he responds
that his name is purpose the red right
hand he is the guardian of o5-1 and None
Shall enter the sanctum until he returns
he is in here ask Calvin no purpose
responds he is and with that he steps
aside and lets Calvin pass through the
doorway the doorway leads into a large
room where screens on the wall flash to
life depicting moments from Calvin's
Journey documenting his entire Quest had
he been in control at all or was this
all a setup to lead him to this moment
as he walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is Aaron Siegel Euro 5-1 Calvin
asks Aaron the man responds my name is
Aaron governor asks about the location
of the second overseer the Nazarene but
o5-1 doesn't respond without needing any
more information Calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a Flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from Aaron before dissolving in a
flash of light Calvin should have known
it wouldn't be this easy stand up Aaron
Siegel Calvin calls up as he holsters
his gun let's finish it Calvin pulled
the Spear of the non-believer from his
back but Aaron's only response was to
laugh
you don't even know why you're here
Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm here to
kill you because when I do I kill the
foundation because when you're gone the
universe can finally heal you're like me
Calvin Lucian we are both men driven by
our own convictions regardless of the
outcome it would seem Fate has brought
us together now either your convictions
will be broken or you will die says
Aaron Siegel he then draws Lucifer's
flaming sword and lunges towards Calvin
Lucian as the two men clash with one
another there's Supernatural weapons
begin to destroy the room around them
Furniture is shattered video screens are
obliterated and fire spreads across the
walls Aaron catches Calvin off balance
and swings the Flaming sword across
Calvin's stomach Calvin slides back from
the impact hunching over from the pain
in his midsection he brings his head up
to see Aaron Siegel running towards him
with a flaming sword high in the air
Alvin brings up the spear from his knees
he leans back and launches it towards
Aaron Siegel the spear enters the final
overseer's chest the force from the
throw pinning him against the wall Aaron
Siegel drops Lucifer's sword it shatters
as it hits the ground he clutches the
shaft of the spear protruding from his
sternum with both hands 05-1 looks at
Calvin unbelievingly
you have no idea what you've done it was
never about the overseers Aaron Siegel
says spitting out blood with every word
it was something deeper something worse
Calvin walks slowly towards Aaron Siegel
he stops just in front of his final
enemy this is the way it ends Calvin
says Aaron Siegel manages to whisper one
final word Sofia before his body finally
goes limp Calvin turns to see purpose
standing behind him he's dead Calvin
says half to purpose and half to himself
I kill them after a moment he asks
purpose what he really wants to know
there's a room in this facility where
someone could unmake the foundation
right take me there without any
hesitation purpose leads Calvin back to
the room with depictions of important
scps their purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
Calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation sites then he sees the single
option the computer is giving him
terminate Calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millimeters from the
button when the phone rings Calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk Calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello Calvin Lucian my name is
the administrator I've been following
your work for some time now and I must
say I am impressed I have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are in order
what the hell are you talking about
Calvin asks please listen says the voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but Aaron Siegel
originally was trying to destroy the
foundation that was until I convinced
him otherwise and now like Aaron Siegel
you will become the new head of the
foundation like hell I will yells Calvin
I could hang up and walk away right
right now and be done with all this you
could continues the administrator but if
no one is in charge of the SCP
Foundation millions of people will die
if not billions and then nobody would be
there to manage what comes after there
is silence from Calvin that's what I
thought says the administrator I look
forward to working with you Calvin
Lucian or should I say
05-1 the line goes dead
the arabora cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this scp-001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborus cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the o5 council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words or Boris
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
well the spelling can differ or Boris
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of Cycles the r bar symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orboros cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of Abaddon this nasty Group
which came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
through at them and were able to
straight up vaporize anyone who got too
close if the kingdom was able to amass
enough power it could spell the end of
the foundation and even the subjugation
of the human race enter 05-1 a
reoccurring character in the orboro
cycle this outside the box thinker put
all his chips on the twins of God
project designated
scp-001 like many in anomalies before
and after it this project would Infuse a
human being with Godlike Powers but it
was a power so great that it seemed to
kill anyone who attempted to accept it
needless to say this was a major bummer
for 05-1 but through Relentless human
experimentation even sacrificing the
population of entire towns to the
project he eventually came up with a
solution a horrifying solution but a
solution nonetheless he found that a
group of nine children with ages varying
from 4 to 11 could act as a human
conduit for 001's power and as a result
it could be a weapon capable of turning
the tide against the kingdom of Abaddon
during the testing phase though it
seemed like 05-1 went a little mad with
power he vaporized an entire church of
the broken God place of worship and used
the power of the children to wipe a few
others off the map at his own discretion
his abuses of power got so flagrant that
the administrator himself was called in
to get a handle on the situation and
surprise
surprise05-1 disintegrated him too
before disappearing himself shortly
afterwards in the end the children were
deemed too dangerous to be practical
both because of their anomalous powers
and from the level of ambient radiation
they put out all nine were locked in
radiation-proof boxes and buried in the
desert though they each show signs of
life to this day while this may seem
disconnected from the rest of the series
it actually establishes some of the most
important reoccurring themes and ideas
of the cycle as a whole namely the
foundation messing with reality and
Performing horrific acts to achieve
their goals the corruption of the o5
council and the fact that these Grand
attempts to change or save the world
often blow up in everyone's Faces
Sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all Is Not What It Seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken in God this tells the chaotic
story of a magical Clockwork box which
is worshiped by the church of the broken
God as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all-devouring
mechanical Kaiju the Beast soon dubbed
scp-001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going Toe to Toe
with a bona fide God a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
scp-2399 the foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly They removed its
Clockwork hard from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous crap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and
instead ended up in a small town here it
began to influence the minds of the
residents into more sub servient broken
God cultists intent on building him back
up to his former glory it'd be easy to
Discount the broken God as an outlier
seeing as the foundation came out
looking much better here than they do in
any of the other orboros Tales but when
you look carefully it's placed in the
overall cycle is clear the entry ends
the way it begins with the heart of the
broken God influencing humans to carry
out its bidding the foundation had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no net loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the orboro cycle atonement once again we
start off with the foundation meddling
with Cosmic scale Powers with the
creation of the area 11 Pietro Cal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was
the machine so powerful it was capable
of creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin Desmond into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed scp-001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the o5 council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unse surprisingly
it was 05-1 that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release
scp-001 having built his consensus among
the survivors on the council 05-1 let
scp-001 out unsurprisingly this turned
out to be a terrible decision as one of
his first acts upon being freed was to
kill the members of the o5 council that
had just voted to release zero zero one
saying that they themselves were
anomalous and needed to be purged to
atone for their past sins the only
Survivor was a member of the council who
abstained from the vote who was able to
recontain
scp-001 inside the Pietro Cal Fontaine
array for now once again the Thematic
connections to the rest of the orboro
cycle is clear we have a world-ending
anomaly held off but only temporarily
buying time before the cycle inevitably
continues we have the foundation abusing
its power and signing off on the death
of countless people in other dimensions
and of course the o5 council stepped out
of their bounds and actively warped
reality just like they had with the
children before their chickens truly
come home to roost though in the final
part of the cycle appropriately named
the way it ends this piece Chronicles
the story of Calvin Lucian and the kill
Squad an elite group of four chaos
Insurgency Soldiers with one goal
assassinating the entire o5 Council 13
of the most powerful people in the world
why because they've been messing with
reality itself time and time again and
it's getting to the point that their
selfish meddling could finally destroy
everything and given that we've already
seen it happen with the children and the
entity that Dr Calvin Desmond became
it's hard to disagree with them what
follows is one of the longest and most
complicated tales in all of the
foundation as the kill Squad
systematically encounters and kills each
insane anomalous member of the o5
council in order to do this they need to
make deals with death itself fight giant
serpents cross Dimensions deal with
scp-610 and scp-682 containment breaches
and go toe-to-toe with samsara arguably
the foundation's deadliest mobile task
force a number of other insane things
happen along the way like 05-1 murdering
the gate Guardian with the Scranton
reality anchor and the black queen the
most prominent member of the Serpent's
hand helping our heroes defeat more over
Sears in the end Calvin Lucien despite
losing almost everything Reigns
victorious in the final battle using the
Spear of the non-believer a weapon so
powerful it can kill Gods Calvin managed
to finally kill the Top member of the
overseers
05-1 with the o5 council destroyed
Calvin said about completing his final
task destroying the entire SCP
Foundation but that didn't happen
instead he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as
the the administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the SCP Foundation to be their new 05-1
this was where our last video on the
arboros series left us what happens next
you may ask how does Calvin respond to
this offer he seemingly can't refuse in
this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is
scp-001 and while it seemed that the
overseers were mad with power they were
actually always there to keep the
administrator in check Aaron Siegler the
05-1 that Calvin had just killed was
doing the exact same thing Calvin was
doing when he became 05-1 trying to
destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the new 05-1 turning his back on the
chaos Insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the foundation in his
own image Insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the oboro cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an o5 Council
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's Calvin Lucian or
Aaron Siegler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devours its own tail the
oboros cycle is and forever will be
Eternal does the black moon howl no not
yet see the boy he was born in a time
before names there weren't enough humans
around to need them back then he was one
of a handful occupying a Coastal Village
using a tongue long since instead they
eked out a simple life hunting Gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications until the hermit appeared
the boy would remember this man for
eternity Haggard and thin skin weathered
by time and pain a man that emaciated
walking with a long gnarled cane that
honestly looked healthier than he did
shouldn't be alive even the boy who had
scarcely seen beyond the bounds of his
village knew that the hermit was
unnatural an aberration an anomaly he
walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large Stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for then a few days
later the black moon howled the boys saw
The Village's youngest Hunter freeze one
evening while out on a walk not simply
stand still but freeze then for an
instant he became solid black a coal
statue and as soon as he'd changed he
was gone obliterated not a trace of him
remained such is the power of the black
moon it can make any conscious being
disappear in an instant turn black then
wiped from our plane of existence never
to be seen again its choice of victims
seemed at each instance to be utterly
random but it would come for all who
lived eventually this is known to some
as the howling of the black moon later
that same night the boy found himself
talking to the hermit who asked with
small frantic eyes what he had seen when
the boy told him he let out a deep
rattling sigh the boy Kerry asked him if
he knew about the nightmare he'd just
witnessed The Hermit looked up he'd been
the first one in the hermit's Millennia
of pursuit that had ever asked in that
moment he knew that he had found his
successor in the hunt for the death of
Ages The Hermit told the boy it went by
many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy though nobody could really be
sure of its true nature The Hermit had
been tracking it learning about it and
trying to destroy it for thousands of
years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One Dustin to face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility
eternal life
eternal youth near physical immortality
but they will be haunted by their
purpose doomed to watch everyone they
love die around them as they continue to
hunt their only true equal and opposite
the black moon itself The Hermit in his
own eyes had failed at its Duty he had
grown weary and now he needed to pass
the duty of counterbalance onto another
that other would be the boy he felt a
sudden and profound change along with
the knowledge that nothing would ever be
the same again he was no longer just the
boy now he was the counterbalance he
watched The Hermit give him a slight nod
of respect and then crumble into dust
before his eyes the boy the
counterbalance the looked up at the sky
and saw the Stars twinkling so bright
and so beautiful little did he know his
battle with the black moon would Outlast
every single one of them does the black
moon howl not without blood the boy grew
into a man as his village aged and then
died around him decades passed then
centuries then Millennia tens of
thousands of years watching Humanity
develop and grow around him as he
continued his pursuit of that one
elusive foe has science and diagnostic
technology gained ground absorbing and
then evolving beyond all the old
superstitions the counterbalance gained
a better understanding of the black moon
though even then it still remained
essentially a stranger The Entity was
entropic a being of pure Randomness and
Chaos without consistent form it didn't
exist in our universe but it could
exercise its influence here with
so-called obliterate events much like
the horrible fate that befell the young
hunter from the village but that was
only the proverbial tip of the iceberg
the counterbalance tracked and noted
obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second he'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
Oddities these anomalies would hold the
key to defeating his Timeless enemy and
it hadn't just been these objects
entities and events he'd also discovered
some truly exceptional people on his
travels minds and skills that rivaled
even his own despite his age perhaps
they would be the ones to help him win
with the 13 most brilliant and trusted
people the counterbalance ever met he
decided to form a council and from this
Council they forged and directed an
organization dedicated to understanding
and counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black moons downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title The Fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power
scp-001 does the black moon howl only at
the blind the year was now 1987. the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability
together Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very Act of engaged observation
defend it the problem is How Can You
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully Creative Solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
specialty Flash Forward to 1993 enter Dr
Moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the SCP
Foundation with the administrator's
consultation he he started the key
project an arm of the wider project
oromasides the umbrella Initiative for
using modified anomalous objects in the
battle against the black moon the goal
of the key project was relatively simple
if people couldn't observe the black
moon directly then the foundation could
make proxies of the black moon that
could be observed almost like a kind of
voodoo doll these new anomalies would
only need to satisfy three criteria the
inability to operate when being observed
a hostility to conscious life and the
ability to end conscious life of their
own volition when not being observed
through conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted to escape by
barging through site-01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even in
a fraction of a second It's relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame in the guilt was too much for Dr
Moto he left a note in his office
Reading we've been looking at nothing
I'm sorry administrator I failed you sir
Moto's corpse was later found in the
sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and its one
surviving creation transported to
site-19 in late 1993 where it was
designated as
SCP-173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counterbalance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of
scp-001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156 when the foundation
launched the seek project under the
support of project oromastes as more and
more people were wiped out in frequent
obliteration events the administrator
became painfully aware that perhaps the
answers to the black moon problem
wouldn't be found on Earth using
state-of-the-art technology with Little
Help from the anomalous the SCP
Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search
the stars for the key to the black
Moon's destruction it was an
awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches seek was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seek derived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
seek Thrones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet
seemed to indicate that the black moon
was responsible for the destruction of
the planet's civilization causing so
many events that the remaining survivors
went mad from the fear and stress
leading to mass death in the ensuing
chaos the next planet was discovered
centuries later in the year 3499 while
this planet could also theoretically
support human life it suffered from
frequent volcanic eruptions that
rendered much of its surface of flaming
Mass however there were still the
dormant ruins of a once Advanced
civilization of conscious beings much
like the prior Planet they'd been driven
extinct by Black Moon obliteration
events a century before the Sikh even
arrived unlike the last planet however
it seems that they accepted their fate
and went gently into the night the
planet was now overrun by billions of
armored bat-like creatures that operated
on pure Instinct and thus were not
considered conscious enough to be
obliterated the final planet was reached
in 3764 and was the most fruitful of the
three discoveries this planet was hyper
Advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega cities with records and
Technology over a thousand years ahead
of Earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and that
developed an awareness of the black
Moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the SCP Foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seek found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen The graft
was immediately instructed to collect
the Survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator Was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codenamed saged was returned to Earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species Sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator later thanks to
his counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation Sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
Sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious State the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waved this Duty passed it on
Sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is SCB the
singular conceptual bunker being worked
on and perfected for thousands of years
by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual Engineers the
administrator replied Victor three but
it will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked Sage asked him what good victory
would do him then rather than say it
aloud he replied with a thought Sage
paused and said I see how Blasphemous of
you hopefully it works after this the
administrator proceeded to the singular
conceptual bunker and entered it leaving
instructions for the foundation to be
run by a newly formed o5 Council in his
indefinite absence thousands of years
later in the year 5011 Sage spoke one
more time repeating the words hopefully
hopefully before turning solid black and
disappearing the black moon had claimed
one more victim but billions more had
gone in the interim the administrator
had no more answers to give at least no
more answers that anyone but him would
understand he was inside the singular
conceptual bunker now loaded into a
device known as Tome an experimental
Memorial module meant to pick up and
record all the last messages of every
dying civilization Across the Universe
when the time finally came all he could
do was wait and wait was exactly what we
did does the black moon howl yes yes it
does years pass too many to count it's a
time after names now and Tome sits in
the very center drinking in the end of
the universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the years 73-29 so so so so long ago but
some of the final messages of fear panic
and distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello hello cabal zero nine four three
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broke underneath my
knee cabal zero nine four three come on
zero nine four three forgive us forgive
us we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources my fault your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault remember I know now rip I
pray now and a small child the last on
Earth simply asking hello into an
indifferent microphone but the
administrator had to wait as the
singular conceptual bunker became the
solitary conceptual bunker he was the
last conscious being in the universe and
still he needed to wait as the Stars
went dark outside only when there was
nothing outside but black was it finally
time for the counterbalances long game
to play off there was nothing left of
our universe the only thing here was the
SCB and the black moon itself with
everything else gone the black moon only
had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and Unleashed both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the head and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he feel the
light fading under the monster's
Relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he'd beat the monster over the
head with it until it's gripped loosened
and he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
Gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
Press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieved laugh
says let there be light and there was
light the Scarlet King is a really bad
guy he's a giant interdimensional
nightmare God intent on breaching our
reality and Wrecking terrible havoc on
everything we know and love he's been
responsible for Untold suffering and
Chaos across countless worlds timelines
and layers of reality to many he's even
somewhat of a final boss to the SCP
Foundation and just when you think he
couldn't get any worse it turns out that
he's also a deadbeat dad not only did
the Scarlet King once have a cult
literally named the children of the
Scarlet King before it was destroyed by
Dr Montauk and the SCP Foundation he
also had at least seven actual children
each one is speculated to be a powerful
anomaly but it's tough to find concrete
answers as to who or what exactly most
of them are so today we're putting on
our researcher hats and digging deep
into the foundation's lore to present
our theories on the potential progeny of
the SCP foundation's greatest enemy and
if nothing else we may finally be able
to get this dark lord of all evil to
start paying all the child support he
probably owes by now first if you're not
well versed in Scarlet King bore you may
be wondering how exactly does an evil
chaos God have kids is there a Scarlet
Queen out there who prefers to stay out
of the Limelight the answer isn't quite
that simple and it has everything to do
with scp-231 and Big Red's most devoted
cult the non-biological Children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have been become known as
scp-231 anyone who accesses those files
and trust us they aren't a pretty sight
we'll find that the containment
procedures mostly involve performing the
infamous Montauk procedure on the
surviving girls to keep them from giving
birth six of the Seven Brides have given
birth to nightmares Beyond Comprehension
and are now dead with only one still
remaining successfully contained but
here at the SCP Foundation you need to
learn to comprehend the incomprehensible
according to a classified document
scp-231 May technically be a neutralized
anomaly without us even knowing and
incidentally this gives us our most
certain answer on the children of the
Scarlet King on this one the Apple fell
very very far from the tree according to
the secret document
scp-999 that's right the adorable Tickle
Monster is the seventh child of the
Scarlet King he must be so disappointed
that everyone's favorite little blob
didn't want to join the family business
of absolute evil for anyone who doesn't
know
scp-999 is a slimy yellow entity that
only seems capable of absolute
compassion it brings joy to everyone in
its presence and with prolonged exposure
it can even cure disorders like PTSD
anxiety and depression he's so good at
this that he even cured
scp-231-7 his de facto mother of her
trauma and allowed her to return happily
to her family after some amnestic
treatment the Scarlet King has another
good reason to be ashamed of his
cheerful blobby's son ancient dividi
prophecy dictates that scp-999 may
someday become so powerful that his
force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if scp-999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who who's The Golden
Child who makes his evil father proud
the real chimp off the old block that
would be our dear reptilian friend as
cp682 the malicious lizard heavily
implied to be a child of the Scarlet
King if you know literally anything
about 682 your reaction to finding out
that he's the spawn of Cruelty
personified is probably yeah that makes
sense just as scp-999 is the Scarlet
King's innocent optimistic young child
682 is kind of like his edgy teenager
still in the middle of a misanthropic
phase he shows no sign of leaving
anytime soon the fact that 682 appears
to find anything about the world around
him utterly disgusting seems to be a
trade he inherited from his dear old dad
and the fact he seems pretty much
impossible to kill also lends Credence
to the popular Theory he's got nightmare
godblood running through his veins 682
has also started displaying a particular
hatred for 999 ever since an incident
where 999 tickled them into submission
so family dinners are probably extra
awkward for these two 999 and 682 are
the most certain children but that still
leaves us with five more children to
identify it's worth remembering that the
waters are murkier from here on in but
we've searched far and wide through the
foundation archives to find possible
answers if your interpretation differs
remember that it's just a theory an SCP
explained Theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here the tail dust and
blood hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory Accord according to One
Foundation theorist this child could
potentially be scp-239 also known as the
witch child this entity is so powerful
that as part of its normal containment
procedures it's eternally kept in a coma
why because this seemingly normal child
has dominion over reality and can change
it to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like scp-682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderkin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory
scp-029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trance-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Khali the Hindu God of
destruction whom has many similarities
to the Scarlet King she certainly fits
the bill of someone capable of raising
armies in the Dark Lord's name one
strike against our Scarlet King
connection theory is that the file
States the daughter of Darkness was
first discovered in India which wouldn't
match up with the other information we
know to be fact however while this is a
long shot given the sensitive nature of
everything involving the Scarlet King
it's extremely possible that false
information was supplied to bury the
connection considering the cover-ups and
lies involving anomalies like scp-1000
this certainly isn't an unprecedented
move on the part of the foundation next
the third child this child is associated
with all things desolation implying
destruction fire ashes pestilence and
death across the battlefield when it
comes to spreading destruction and Death
on a mass scale one particular SCP comes
to mind
scp-058 the Heart of Darkness this
creature has Scarlet King written all
over it it's evil it's mysterious it's
pretty much impossible to kill and it
causes Mass casualties every time it
escapes its containment chamber it
causes fires whips people to death with
its razor-sharp tendrils and spraying's
highly corrosive acid from its
scorpion-like tail and it's even red
given that we know for a fact this
entity suddenly emerged out of something
that's now been expunged from the
records in an undisclosed site it's
extremely possible that the entity 058
came from was
scp-231-3 this is a child that the
Scarlet king would definitely be proud
of given that it's impossible to reason
with and feels solely motivated by
causing destruction misery and Chaos we
can't think of an entity that better
suits the Desolation moniker than
scp-058 next skipping past scp-682 at
number four the fifth child of the
Scarlet King is associated with the
loose concept of lack the prophecy then
goes into more detail saying that this
child is powerful in the ways of magic
and is able to use their abilities to
cause great destruction here we have
another unconventional proposal what if
child number five wasn't actually a
child but chill children that's because
we think this description perfectly fits
scp-1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their past
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their
ringleader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the Scarlet
King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the Scarlet King the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting
scp-055 the anti-mean but since we're
having fun here we also want to make an
even Wilder suggestion we posit that the
sixth child of the Scarlet King is
Alison Chao also known as LS and the
black queen the most powerful member of
the Serpent's hand we get it we have a
lot of explaining to do but hear us out
Alison Chao is a member of the Serpent's
hand or technically many members
multiple versions of her exist across
parallel dimensions in the SCP
Multiverse they're mostly all as strange
Daughters of foundation researcher Dr
Charles kears this estrangement leads
them to collaborate in The Wanderers
Library the secret base of the Serpent's
hand to conduct raids on the foundation
in Revenge but what if the leader of
these alternate allicins had an ulterior
motive because in the infinite number of
possibilities offered by the Multiverse
this one was not the daughter of Charles
gears but the Scarlet King she's merely
using the pain of her counterparts to
manipulate them into accomplishing her
true father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesized to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Allison Chao appear human the use of
scp-2 68 a Newsboy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
King's entrance into our Dimension and
Allison Chao has access to The Wanderers
Library an unfettered access point
between Dimensions if one of the
infinite allicins was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet King with The
Wanderers Library not be a perfect way
for him to leave his own Dimension and
enter ours she could be the final piece
he needs hidden under the nose of the
foundation and the Serpent's hand making
all the secret power plays to allow for
the Scarlet Kings eventual bloody
revenge on our world unless of course
scp-999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us anytime
any changes today the younger security
officer Zach asked as he stepped into
the Watchtower as if provide his
Superior a jaded cynical old man who
insisted on being referred to as Mr
Jefferson a darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then
through the window the pair of them
looked through at the Towering figure a
few kilometers away
scp-001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like these security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the transfer posting Zach asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw it Mr
Jefferson scoffed rolling his eyes what
possesses someone like Robert Montauk to
come down here and must have wanted a
quieter post Zach recent looking out at
the Stillness of the gate Guardian won't
find one any quieter than here Jefferson
him showing up will be the most exciting
thing that's happened here in a long
while unbeknownst to both Zach and Mr
Jefferson Dr Robert Montauk would be
only joining the team at the gate
Guardian observation site for a short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
montauk's true intentions behind
venturing there in the first place he
wanted an audience with a gay Guardian
itself approaching the Colossal thousand
foot tall being Dr Montauk crossed the
threshold of the minimum safe distance
from the guardian given the sheer heat
of its weapon hotter than Earth's sun
anything within a kilometer of scp-001
was at risk of being obliterated
vaporized into atoms if they didn't turn
back which through a voice that
immediately rang out in montauk's ears
the gate Guardian commanded him to do
it's psychic message boomed wait wait Dr
Montauk urged holding up his hands in
what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute it was silence
scp-001 didn't reply there was nobody
else close enough to hear Montauk speak
to it so he continued you are impossibly
old we know that much about you and
because of that you must have seen
things that we can't even begin to
imagine much less fully comprehend but
I've come a very long way to request
that you impart some information
if you can he paused again as if waiting
for a reply that never came the gate
Guardian merely stood in the same
defensive unwavering stance tell me
please how much do you know about the
Scarlet King by this point in time
although the foundation was yet to
realize Dr Robert Montauk was slowly
going insane his investigations into an
anomalous entity known as The Scarlet
King were gradually corrupting him as he
tried relentlessly to quantify exactly
what this entity was and how great of a
threat it posed little did Montauk
realize that in trying so hard to Define
and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional
warmongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Montauk was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the immensuke guardian rebuted
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before Witness
as if his increasing instability and the
creeping influence of the Scarlet King
hadn't made Montauk feel bad enough he
instantly felt sick there was a searing
pain behind his eyes like he was staring
directly at the sun accompanied by a
nausea that made his head spin it took a
moment of enduring the horrific
sensation before he realized what was
happening the guardian was trying to
show him something rather than give any
information on the Scarlet King verbally
scp-001 was imparting a psychic Vision
on to Montauk a memory of events long
past the answers he saw a warning or
perhaps all three the vision showed
Montauk a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was eons in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity the time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the David civilization some of the
earliest worshipers of the Scarlet King
himself and there marching up to the
entrance of Eden was the crimson-clad
Eldritch Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
before he assumed his now Infamous title
back then he would most likely have been
known as his original name of Contra one
of multiple siblings born when the tree
of life was planted and thus created all
life in the Multiverse but being the
only one of his siblings cursed with
awareness knowing the pain his existence
brought him comprock would eventually
set out on his lifelong mission to
destroy all of existence across every
Dimension and he started by killing his
siblings can assuming them to claim
their power for himself around this time
in pre-history the being that would one
day become known as Scarlet King didn't
quite possess the power that he would
several Millennia later although that's
not to say he was an unformidable force
of Destruction fueled by his singular
hatred for existence his vow to destroy
extended to the tree of life that had
caused him to be along with the tree's
Creator and all of their Creation in
other words everything in the Multiverse
all of creation if you will so what was
the Scarlet King doing there so long ago
at the dimensional doorway protected by
the gate Guardian while beyond the
boundary between it and the rest of the
infinite Multiverse lay the supposed
Garden of Eden while it is unknown if it
is in fact the same Eden referred to in
the Book of Genesis is Up For Debate
especially among the foundation but at a
glance even through the gate it
certainly does look like a paradise this
is filled with Lush vegetation of
astronomical size populated by a number
of beings that seem to resemble the gate
Guardian itself and they are protected
by its watchful caretaker are two trees
one is thought to be the tree of
knowledge that Eve was tricked into
eating an apple from during the Book of
Genesis the other however Bears an
unknown type of fruit and is widely
believed to be the tree
now back in the Modern Age there's never
been a conclusive link between the Tree
of Life mentioned by the davites and
their barbaric civilizations Legends
regarding the creation of the Scarlet
King but the fact that so long ago he
and his most feared generals were
bearing down on the gate guardian's
position defending a garden where there
was known to be a tree of that
description well it all seems rather
conclusive now alongside kakarak were
six of his Seven Daughters each one of
them a fearsome Abomination much like
their destructive father as they
approached not one needed to exchange
any words with their Angelic protector
of Eden the gate Guardian knew what
these monsters were here for they would
stop at nothing to pass through his gate
and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
cataract's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever and his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as camparak
himself wielding a flaming sword
Boom the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian it was like a doorman standing
before a group of Rowdy teenagers trying
to force their way into a movie theater
except these Rowdy teens were the
Scarlet King his horrifying daughters
and the forces he had already amassed
since its Creation The Horde stood ready
waiting for the commands of their King
who they thought would gladly lead the
charge as they marched on the Garden of
Eden to begin the destruction of
existence but that's not what happened
usually the Scarlet king would never shy
away from a fight preferring to lead the
charge when it came to a Slaughter
instead he commanded his first daughter
to commence the first attack on the
protector who stood in their path on her
foul father's word ativig took her horde
and charged at the guardian when she and
her forces lacked a numerical Advantage
ativic more than made up for in her
knowledge of War she hungered for it
sock Dominion that was her seal after
all and yet in the face of this
impending onslaught the gate Guardian
remains still rooted to the same spot it
had as always it would always be
standing in a number of ativic's minions
burst into flames the very fabric of
their crude forms separated on a
molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appeared
to move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to ativic
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and held in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter
to send forth her own Army in a tidal
wave of night nurished creatures agor
sent her horrific children into battle
she possessed a far greater quantity to
do battle on her father's behalf perhaps
akhar even believed that was the Scarlet
King's plan with a greater number of her
forces over her sisters Maybe she would
be able to overwhelm the guardian but
even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate Agro had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that kampra could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anklet was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle under cells
just how easily the gate Guardians
seemed to be eliminating the oncoming
forces without even moving while an out
relief frail seeming creature anhuit's
primary strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her innate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her
it was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing
anthuit's abilities as a threat to his
leadership and so kanthrak had her
crippled and all her children leaving
them unable to overthrow him but still
loyal to their King obeying her father's
command perhaps out of the same guilty
or fear that he would harm her and her
children further if she disobeyed anui
unfurled her magic she reshaped the
world around them making it so that the
passage of time moves so much slower and
that was what revealed to the Scarlet
King his enemy's greatest strength in
combat the gate Guardian had so far been
able to obliterate both ativic and now
agra's forces without seeming to move
but it wasn't by standing still it was
moving just much faster than the blink
of scarlet King's multiple eyes now that
Anthony's magic had slowed the passage
of time the gate Guardian could be seen
during battle as agra's atrocities
spilled towards the angel to try and
overwhelm it it effortlessly blocked the
oncoming attacks with its sword
everything the Flaming blade connected
with instantly evaporated bursting into
atoms as they were practically cleaved
out of existence by the gate guardian's
Mighty weapon even with time slowed to a
crawl The Towering Wing protector of
Eden only he appeared to be moving at an
average speed but when time flowed
normally without Uncle manipulating
reality the guardian was simply too fast
to be observed resisting the urge to
dive headfirst into the fight himself
the Scarlet King knew it would likely
lead to his untimely demise he refused
to accept that it could not happen but
he still had yet to amass the strength
he would need as he continued his Ascent
so while time was slowed to a crawl and
the gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protector's focus was
diverted ADI son Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of vapor heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the garden as adisad
sent forth her power blood and Ash soak
the landscape around them all the plants
outside the entrance to Eden withered
and died shriveling and decomposing as
the disgusting fog rolled towards the
gate it washed over the guardian whose
form only seemed to Glow brighter as he
repelled the pestilence it was as if it
didn't even need to think about it still
focused on finishing off the rest of the
oncoming Army as its glow intensified so
did the fiery sword that the gate
Guardian swung with ease and finesse
flames burst from the blade the
encroaching fumes Catching Fire along
with the air itself it ignited in a wave
of fire a defensive Inferno that
repelled this latest attack but for a
brief few moments while time stayed slow
before enruits hold on reality
inevitably broke the king had sent forth
atilif of all his spawns she was the
most reserved keeping mostly to herself
never speaking she and her children
could change their faces and forms shift
into anything or anyone and walk
undetected through the Multiverse and
now her father was employing her
incredible stealth abilities to slip
Behind Enemy Lines while the gate
Guardian was finishing off the remaining
Onslaught from cockroach's other
daughters it was as attilift Drew near
creeping unseen closer and closer to the
entrance keeping the Scarlet King out of
Eden that the guardian seemed to pause
it slowly ominously turned its huge head
tilting until it was looking directly at
atilif if its expression could be seen
maybe the gate Guardian would almost be
impressed that someone was able to sneak
past it after all was a feat that no
other being in creation could ever hope
to accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon to live with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled the tidal
wave of fire that engulfed everything
around it not just active but ativic
akhor and adista all the king's
daughters that had attacked so far along
with every one of their own children
were instantly obliterated they were all
reduced to empty vacant spaces where
they had once been their atoms separated
by the Searing swing of the guardian's
weapon the devastating Blow by his
adversary did little to deter the
Scarlet King from his mission he was
still set on destroying the tree of life
and no loss was too great in his pursuit
of destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anhuit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet King
could simply make her restore her Fallen
sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had held back for too long
and slowly drew his own weapon out of
thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their
both the ancient Angelic Defender and
the attacking Eldritch Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong parent a weapon
of extreme all-consuming heat block
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with comcrack the
force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
cane who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he'd need
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unwards slowing down time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate fine
that was it the Scarlet King needed more
time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill comfrock its flaming
weapon could cleave him out of existence
and that would end the king's torment
but it wouldn't be enough a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with a gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eons amassing more and more
power than when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert Montauk looked up at
the still silent form of the gate
Guardian did you do it he yelled
desperate to know more through his
obsession with the Scarlet King did you
tell him yes did you make a deal there
was no answer from the guardian just a
single word that echoed through
montauk's fractured mind
the SCP Foundation has faced a number of
wide potentially apocalyptic threats in
its mission to uphold normalcy and save
Humanity we know the SCP Foundation
could be ruthless in this Mission the
events of scp-5000 before agent Pietro
restarted the Universe show what happens
when the foundation is pushed to its
final decisions regarding normalcy being
upheld in scp-5000 it seemed that the
SCP Foundation decided to seize research
further into the anomaly they needed to
neutralize but what would have happened
if they didn't in any case we know the
SCP Foundation is dedicated to normalcy
and the containment of the anomalous but
what happens when the SCP Foundation is
faced with a dire decision uphold
normalcy or destroy their Universe the
Multiverse is a concept in science
fiction that has gained Mass amounts of
popularity over recent years especially
recently thanks to a certain wall
crawlers movie multiverses are parallel
universes that are similar or extremely
different from the main ones scientists
have pondered over the existence of a
Multiverse for hundreds of years but the
most popular being the many worlds
interpretation a theory of quantum
mechanics that states there are many
worlds that exist in parallel at the
same space and time as our own some
interpretations even state that every
decision a person makes causes a branch
in reality where the person made the
other decision we're familiar with the
SCP foundation's run-ins with the
Multiverse from
scp-2935 O Death a cave that allows The
Wanderer to enter a parallel Dimension
that's fully and completely dead only
for the same thing to happen to their
own world once they return through the
cave or
scp-1437 a hole that allows the
foundation to send receive and read
parallel dimensional documentation from
other multiversal SCP foundations
combine those two concepts with an
scp-001 proposal the importance of an
scp-001 proposal is not lost on the
foundation researchers of the SCP
Foundation saved the scp-001 slot for
only the most dangerous apocalyptic or
widespread anomalies that could affect
the foundation itself humanity and
normalcy arbelix scp-001 proposal and
the research within its file found the
answer to the question we posed above
when the SCP Foundation is faced with a
dire decision do they uphold normalcy or
destroy their Universe in all the people
who live in it the file begins somewhat
different from what we're used to with
SCP Foundation files instead of an item
number or containment procedures we
begin with a yellow notice from the
records and information security
administration or racer for short the
notice states that the following file
was received in 2026 from Dimension r
r42 his Dimension r42 potentially the
cause of scp-001 could they be attacking
this version of the SCP Foundation the
notice continues with the description of
the file that follows it it states the
file below describes an anomaly
threatening all members of humankind in
all of the Multiverse this file had been
emitted to this version of the SCP
Foundation for eight minutes as an
extremely dangerous Cognito Hazard
classified as a class 5 Cognito Hazard
capable of easily destabilizing and
penetrating this universe however it was
found to not be dangerous only reading
as a danger level zero while this
Foundation was unable to quickly
counteract this Cognito Hazard it
appeared to not pose a threat to the
affected universe's humankind part of
this notice is crossed out indicating
that it is no longer true there is a
high threat of repeated Cognito
hazardous or other forms of attack from
Dimension r42 instead this part has been
replaced with the following fact
Dimension r42 no longer exists did this
version's SCP Foundation fall to scp-001
their entire universe no longer exists
so perhaps this file that this
Dimensions SCP Foundation received could
be a potential warning under this race
and notice the reader is not greeted
with the standard foundation
documentation yet again instead it seems
that the original senders of this file
left a note for the readers of this file
it says greetings you are reading this
dossier in a para dimension of The Relic
Dimension r42 due to the Colossal size
of your world's address for your
convenience your dimension will be
Hereafter referred to as PD
paradimensions it seems as though we're
reading this scp-001 file Through The
Eyes of the SCP Foundation in this
so-called para Dimension so so if the
original SCP Foundation and their
universe r-42 is now destroyed what does
this mean for us the note continues the
following message has been constructed
by the SCP Foundation of The Relic
Dimension r42 and is addressed to the
SCP Foundation of paradimension PD
enclosed you will find information about
scp-001 which is a threat to the
Multiverse here we go
scp-001 is definitely the cause of r42's
Destruction but how can we be so sure of
this maybe scp-001 caused the foundation
to destroy their Universe the node also
includes the following statement as you
may have noticed this message was
preceded by a burst signal containing a
non-dangerous Cognito Hazard the best
signal was constructed in such a way
that minimal change to the signal would
have caused indiscriminate and
overwhelming casualties among the
denizens of PD as you can see all 42 is
capable of eliminating the absolute
majority of PD denizens but has not
exercised this capability in the context
above we ask you to consider this action
not as an act of aggression but as a
demonstration of the fact that r42 has
no pretension for conquest or other
forms of aggression towards PD take the
following information in Earnest well at
least this version of the SCP Foundation
is being somewhat friendly with the
parent Dimension if r42s as CP
Foundation needs to quell this
multiversal threat though why are they
leaving it up to an SCP Foundation that
may not be so inclined the scp-001 file
begins with the object class this
anomaly is of the joint class of paradox
apollyon we know from scp-001 when
daybreaks or scp-3999 that a polyon
class anomalies are extremely dangerous
posing an immediate and almost
Unstoppable threat to normalcy the s CP
Foundation all of humanity or even the
universe itself the Paradox part is
interesting what exactly is paradoxical
about an appallian-class anomaly a
footnote explains this for us this
anomalies distinguishing feature is that
in order to eliminate the anomaly that
will inevitably eliminate mankind it is
imperative to eliminate mankind or
release another k-class event oh boy it
seems that the SCP Foundation of r42 was
not eliminated by scp-001 they
eliminated themselves to contain
scp-001 is this para-dimension faced
with this decision now the containment
procedures of the SCP file continue on
this note the only way to contain
scp-001 and prevent a ZK class
cross-reality failure event is the
annihilation of humankind k-class
scenarios are not a concept used lightly
by the SCP found Foundation we're
familiar with the Omega K class scenario
when we are completely rid of death or
XK Class end of the world scenarios so
we know the danger these anomalies hold
to humankind normalcy and the world the
SCP Foundation will do anything to
prevent these scenarios from occurring
apparently even including the
elimination of all humankind or entire
universes the description goes more in
depth on the scp-001 anomaly
scp-001 consists of all living members
of the homo sapiens species living
within Dimension r42 and the para
Dimension or PD for short it seems as
though this anomaly was created out of a
mistake from Dimension r42 and PD as the
description States the anomaly first
came into existence and developed in The
Relic Dimension r42 and later activated
in PD by accident how could this have
happened are these Dimensions linked
much more closely than we first thought
let's continue with the description to
find more information scarily this
portion of the description contains a
note that states that unchecked growth
of scp-001 will cause the annihilation
of the entire Multiverse the SCP
foundations of Dimension r42 and PD are
not met with this decision as now the
entire Multiverse is at risk the r42 SCP
Foundation has done immense research on
the topic of the Multiverse of their
Universe after the big bang a finite
number of universes were created only 57
to be exact however only one dimension
was able to form Humanity Dimension r42
and it's unknown why this happened but
all we know is that with the destruction
of r42 and the potential annihilation of
PD Humanity will cease to exist in the
Multiverse the danger of scp-001 is that
it has the anomalous capability for wide
scale replication of paired Dimensions
we are reading this article from one of
these para Dimensions so this SCP
Foundation is technically an anomaly
that must contain itself a pair
Dimension is defined as a parallel
reality that has an extremely small
deviation from its parent dimension in
this case PD is a para dimension of r42
it seems that these pair Dimensions form
as a result of human decision making so
if you've ever been between a type of
shirt to buy or were confused on an exam
and guessed a question a pair Dimension
could have formed from this decision
where the pair Dimension has you take
the other choice because of this
Dimensions housing living instances of
scp-001 uncontrollably grow a colossal
number of minimally differing pair
Dimensions every second no sign of
paired Dimensions have been found in the
other 56 parent Dimensions the picture
on this file shows how PD has branched
from r42 but at this point it seems that
Millions if not billions or trillions of
pair Dimensions now exist the real
problem of para Dimensions is that the
Multiverse has a limit on the number of
pair Dimensions that can exist and once
that is crossed the ZK class cross
reality failure event will begin and the
Multiverse will be destroyed the r42
dimensions SCP Foundation has also
discovered that once humankind emerges
in the pair Dimension they can begin to
have para Dimensions themselves the ZK
class cross-reality failure event can be
expected to begin between four to two
months from the PD receiving this
message to summarize
scp-001 is humankind specifically it's
decision making when a person makes a
decision a pair of Dimension may be
created the Multiverse has a limit on
the number of pair Dimensions it can
have and since pair Dimensions can have
paired Dimensions they are quickly
approaching the ZK class cross reality
failure event the SCP Foundation of of
r42 is approximately 17 years ahead of
PD which allowed them to research and
develop containment procedures to
contain the anomaly and save the
Multiverse r42's SCP Foundation
discovered scp-001 five years before
writing the file we're reading now aside
from that they developed two operations
castling and minimal gain to slow pair
Dimension creation and prevent the ZK
class cross-reality failure event in
stage 1 of operation minimal gain the
foundation began with neutralizing and
decommissioning all of their contained
anomalies under the classification of
Euclid or ketter specifically those that
were expensive to contain or requiring
high levels of personnel and researchers
stage 2 saw operation castling be
commenced the r42 SCP Foundation
launched Rockets with variant C Global
amnestic dispersing warheads and took
control over all countries in order to
hold power over all humankind in stage 3
the foundation began to move their world
to a more natural state destroying all
hazardous radioactive chemical and
bacteriological objects removing dams
and stopping oil extractions during
stage 3 stage 4 began the r42 SCP
Foundation began eliminating Humanity in
third world countries by use of viral
and biological attacks Stage 5 was a
wider spread attack on Humanity where
the SCP Foundation added deactivation
resistant viral agents to water
treatment and collection plants food
products medication and household items
of developed countries by stage 6 only
0.1 percent of humanity remained and
they were targeted with drone strikes or
put into concentration camps for
elimination stage seven of the remaining
survivors the foundation sampled them to
find the fittest of those left to
preserve humankind stage 8 saw 15 000 of
these people put into indefinite
cryosleep and the remaining survivors
were eliminated Stage Nine saw the
destruction of the remaining SCP
Foundation Personnel we move on to a
list of proposals that were made before
or during operations castling and
minimal gain proposals rejected include
the use of SCP objects or other
Technologies to eliminate derivative
Dimensions the development of Nanobots
with the capability to control human
decision-making capabilities and
eliminate variability full replacement
of humanity with bionic hybrids acting
explicitly within standard behavioral
models unification of humanity into a
neural network with control given to an
AI Control unit and the destruction of
Earth and or all of its inhabitants
While most of these seem like Clear
Solutions that would prevent the
elimination of humanity at the SCP
foundation's hand these proposed were
all rejected for one reason the SCP
Foundation did not have enough time one
proposal was accepted however the use of
scp-0000 this appears to be the solution
the r42 SCP Foundation concocted to
fight
scp-001 and potentially save the
Multiverse it poses the question if the
r42 SCP Foundation used this same
anomaly to contain scp-001 as proven by
the fact they no longer exist will PD do
the same the file explains that the
r42scp foundation opened a dimensional
Wormhole into PD as they do not know at
the time if para Dimensions could cause
the creation of more para dimensions in
doing this the SCP Foundation seemingly
infected PD with the ability to create
para Dimensions the author of this file
goes on to explain that the r42scp
foundation had plans to attack PD and
use operations castling and minimal gain
in the dimension however they could not
access the dimension again and they
believed that the foundation Personnel
of PD would have made use of thumbnail
class anomalies to save themselves and
their world a note from r42's overseer
council is left for PD if the apollian
destruction was not enough the overseer
council is involved the importance of
the neutralization of this anomaly
cannot be forgotten so the overseer
Council explained to PD the world has
existed before us and must remain after
us our Multiverse is ill and the name of
the illness is Humanity
scp-001 the only way out is
scp-0000
will cease to become a threat with its
Health it is in our power to leave a
chance for other Sapient species that
perhaps will not be affected by the same
anomaly but will find a way to get rid
of it before it's too late we the o5
council and other survivors from r42
have chosen Our Fate we hope you will do
the same what is this scp-0000 how did
the SCP Foundation of r42 find the
solution the file for scp-0000 is placed
within this
scp-001 file
scp-0000 is a paradox thumbnail class
anomaly without any containment
procedures
scp-0000 is a device that once activated
will destroy the universe it was
activated in it will also destroy all
para Dimensions that are not creating
other para Dimensions as such PD would
not be destroyed however the billions or
trillions of other para Dimensions the
r42 parent Dimension created will be
destroyed PD is left with a harrowing
decision to continue living or does
destroy itself to save the rest of the
Multiverse in the file a note from r42's
Jones Simpson is written for an SCP
Foundation overseer 05-1 as part of
operations castling and minimal gain the
remaining Foundation employees were
allowed one family member to uphold
morale Joan is not writing for r42's
05-1 instead she's writing for
pds05-1 this Dimensions version of her
father she begins with wondering whether
she can call this version of 05-1 her
father as her version of her father
recently passed away she remembers the
day the foundation employees were
allowed to choose that one family member
they would save for the time being her
father was opposed to allowing two
family members as he claimed it would
cause unnecessary stress and schisms
among the remaining few hundred
Foundation staff 05-1 chose to have Joan
over her mother and she understood stood
everything by the look in his eyes and
grew angry but that feeling is long gone
now she began to work with her father
and the remaining Foundation Personnel
that called themselves hostages behind
the backs of those higher up the ranks
on days she felt sad Joan and her father
would go up to the surface of the Earth
in hazmat suits sitting on the grass and
watching over the empty City at the
bottom of the mountain no Humanity
remained with the only life she could
see being Birds her father promised her
that they'd returned there and build a
giant Monument to humanity at the center
of the city she knew this was a lie Joan
remembers when someone proposed that
they should open a portal the one that
opened to PD this was their fatal
mistake as after that the paradimension
began replicating para Dimensions the
countdown went down two months again and
the promise he made to his daughter
became impossible 05-1 died and left the
position vacant Jones says to the
pd's05-1 that she doesn't care whether
they destroy their world or not or
whether the universe will continue to
exist or if there will be new life in it
her world was crushed long ago the note
also reads the following it's good that
this message is encrypted with your key
that was passed on to me or these lines
would have been deleted everyone wants
to save the world but who needs it like
this empty and cold without those to
appreciate its beauty without Humanity
do whatever you think is right I truly
feel better now love you Faithfully
Yours Joan Simpson we're not too sure if
PD went through with destroying their
Universe to save the Multiverse but it
seems that whatever decision was made
would cause the destruction of that
Universe whether that be through the use
of scp-0000 or the ZK class cross
reality failure event Humanity will
cease but maybe if they make the
decision use
scp-0000 Sapient life can begin to exist
again and hopefully no pair Dimensions
will be made from their decisions
decisions are an extremely innate part
of humanity you decided to get out of
bed this morning you decided to open up
your computer or phone and you decided
to watch this video who knows the amount
of para Dimensions we may have created
today but in our world we're not at risk
but in the SCP foundation's Universe
anything can be anomalous even Humanity
if you're familiar with the SCP
Foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple
scp-001s you may even think you know
which of them is the real
scp-001 but for those of you who are new
here or who just need a little reminder
the designation of scp-001 doesn't refer
to a single creature or object or entity
but rather a collection of various
anomalies that are apparently kept in
containment by the SCP Foundation at
present it is unclear why there are
multiple files collected under the
shared designation of
scp-001 some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the foundation this would
mean that they share the designation of
scp-001 as they were likely encountered
before the SCP Foundation introduced
their current numbering system however
there also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection perhaps the multiple
scp-001 files are an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information about
the true
scp-001 after all it wouldn't be the
first time this hyper-secretive
organization deceived us anomaly sharing
the name as cp001 include the infamous
Scarlet King the massive gate guardian
and the world-ending events no known as
when day breaks but today we'll be using
scp-001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location code
named God's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the SCP Foundation constructed and
designated as facility T according to
their archive it's a largely
unremarkable Place situated at a spot on
the Sinai Peninsula which is a part of
Egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of Africa and Asia in the
18th century archaeologists Excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium
BC however since the construction of
facility T any trace of this structure
has since disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
SCP Foundation why establish a facility
if there was nothing in anomalous about
its nature what distinguishes this
scp-001 site in the eyes of the
foundation is the area's profound lack
of any ambient Akiva radiation but what
is a Kiva radiation well according to
the foundation's researchers it's a form
of cosmic background radiation one
that's not overtly harmful to human
beings if you grew up in a strict
church-going household then it's highly
likely you would have been exposed to a
lot of this non-electromagnetic
radiation and never even realized it you
see the thing with Akiva radiation is
that it is directly correlated with the
amount of religious Faith a person has
regardless of which religion someone
follows Akiva radiation will form around
them it tends to be harmless to humans
however certain anomalous entities and
scps considered to be demonic in nature
can be repelled and even fought off with
high levels of Akiva radiation the
presence of other powerful anomalies
those considered more benign or even
holy can also create an increase in this
radiation
scp-001 has earned the nickname God's
blind spot for a number of reasons one
being that it is the only place on Earth
with the natural absence of this Akiva
radiation the foundation has conducted
experiments that involve bringing
sources known to emit Akiva radiation
into the area of scp-001 but when they
measured no change in radiation levels
was detected meaning that the space
around facility T does not actively
block Akiva radiation from entering it
but also cannot absorb or retain this
religious radiation it might be more
accurate to say that the location
destroys any trace of residual Akiva
without damaging The Source a lack of
faith field radiation is far from the
only anomalous property of scp-001
though during a number of tests
involving d-class personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in the containment cell on the
scp-001 site and observed he had no
supplies no food no water yet over 120
days this man stayed alive never
succumbing to starvation or dehydration
next a female member of d-class was
exposed to a lethal dose of cyanide gas
within facility T and suffered none of
the expected of facts Foundation
researchers then repeated this cyanide
gas test using 30 common brown rats all
of which were killed proving that it was
only humans that couldn't be killed
while within
scp-001 God's blind spot seems to also
be able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage 4 cancer was brought
into
scp-001 the spider prognosis stating
that she would be dead imminently the
woman survived in the area for almost
800 days her cancer symptoms never
Advanced and she only died after finally
leaving the area of
scp-001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations Foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of scp-001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final tests to take
place with an scp-001 involved a pair of
24 year old identical d-class twins one
of the twins designated twin a was held
at facility T while the other twin B was
imprisoned in a Cell at a different
Foundation site after observing them for
over 26 years twin B aged naturally to
the age of 50. his twin however did not
appear to age at all over the course of
Two and a Half decades it was only one
moved to another facility that twin a
began to show signs of aging the aging
process for twin a was rapid too and
eventually he caught up with his brother
being a benign non-threatening anomaly
the foundation has been more than happy
to use God's blind spot to their own
Advantage facility T was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the o5 council the
overseers of the entire SCP Foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
Council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
Earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay of course
this locked the o5 council to one
location but what if they could
replicate the effects of scp-001
Elsewhere of of course this is what the
SCP Foundation attempted following their
Research into God's blind spot the
foundation's own Dr Marvin Scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his Hope was by generating a vacuum of
Akiva radiation that a second instance
of scp-001 would occur at a location of
his choosing or as his assistant
Bertrand put it they plan to build a box
and then push God out of it as it turned
out God had other plans Dr Scranton
quickly realized the hubris of his
scheme the Akiva radiation in the
selected area rapidly dropped to zero
just as planned but then something
unexpected happened Scranton detected an
increase in Humes these are essentially
parts of the fabric of reality and are
what's often disrupted by reality
bending as CPS something had come into
our world thanks to the o5 council's
attempt to recreate
scp-001 something impossible for the
foundation to measure or observe in
other words Scranton had no idea what he
Unleashed or where it went following
this incident the o5 council realized a
worrying increase in the anomalous
incidents they were encountering whether
or not this came as a direct result of
their meddling with the fabric of the
universe was unclear but it forced the
council to reconsider the focus and
direction of the entire SCP Foundation
up until this point they had been an
organization focused purely on research
but now they had to embrace a new
approach to how they handled anomalies
from then on the foundation's objective
became to actively seek out and contain
anomalous entities creatures objects and
locations like
scp-001 rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
scp-001's file is a memorandum detailing
and Arrangement between the o5 council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named Sheldon Katz set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility T Sheldon
states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the SCP Foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with Scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the o5 council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer Council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on Earth well an
actual higher power of course that's
right the o5 council was making a deal
with God over how they were allowed to
use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be God the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of scp-001
for more than 120 years including
members of the o5 council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects additionally
the SCP foundation's Ethics Committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the o5 council's decisions to God
for his own part God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation Personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the
clock Divine protection at least from
God himself that's still a lot better
than an employee dental plan this came
with a condition however that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin
was given a 90-day written notice and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing
in return God demanded that members of
the foundation only worshiped him and no
other Divine entities I the Lord am a
jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children unto the third
and fourth generation of them that hate
me was written in the contract finally
the agreement between the o5 council and
God was that they would work together
the foundation and the counterparty
would be equal Partners when it came to
the containment of scps and anomalies of
all the strange and unexplained
phenomena that the SCP Foundation
encounters on a regular basis it hardly
comes as much of a surprise that they've
got a direct line to the big guy
upstairs or at least one who purports to
be still the fact that the o5 council
have a business arrangement with an
ultra powerful deity like being and
express written permission to use his
blind spot where no person can die or
age is hardly a comforting thought at
least the SCP Foundation only ever uses
its power for good right while some
higher level researchers specialized
guards and containment experts at the
SCP Foundation have fixed anomalous
projects tailored to their very
particular set of skills for many lower
level operatives including Junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded d-classes every day is
showing up spinning the wheel of
Misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to Pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll eaten alive made into
a living Nest by bugs stretched out and
broken drowned exsanguinated set on fire
beaten to death by a volleyball
anomalous tomatoes because you decided
to drop a cringe-worthy dad joke or a
rancid pun there are perhaps only a
handful of anomalies that not only will
not harm you but will actively enrich
your life by getting to spend time with
them and of course Chief among these is
the legendary
scp-999 also known by its adorable
moniker the Tickle Monster we don't need
to get into too much detail in
describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by scp-682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on scp-999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M M's in hand
the creature cooed perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured M
M's into its eager mouth radiating Good
Vibes the whole time what an asset what
a gift and to think this adorable little
goober was prophesized to someday save
the world that much seemed almost funny
but he was certainly more than capable
of saving the life of someone who hadn't
felt the warmth of internal sunshine in
quite some time and for that much the
researcher was profoundly grateful he
left 999's chamber that day with a
renewed sense of hope for the future
that maybe just maybe they might be able
to pull through to make a difference to
push this crazy ball of rock we call our
home in the right direction maybe
someday the Sun would rise on a perfect
world who would have thought that a
strange Sunrise could change everything
emergency Sirens went off across the
globe but in every case they were
drowned out by a terrible endless chorus
of Screams but below all that you'll
hear another gut-wrenching sound a low
but pervasive sizzling like an egg on a
hot pan as billions of human beings
started to change their states of matter
the SCP Foundation had fought off and
contained so many seemingly impossible
threats from interdimensional Horrors
like the hanged sealed and Scarlet Kings
to nightmarish Mass Killers like scp-106
the old man
scp-096 the Shy Guy and scp-682 the hard
to destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good would
any of it do when the very center of our
solar system decided in an instant that
rather being the linchpin of our
delicate cradle of life it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was
answered upon the emergence of
scp-001 a terrible day also known as
when day breaks in the snap of one's
fingers half the world was plunged into
Terror and death rays of Stark red light
swept through the streets people lucky
enough to be in the shade or inside
buildings with a view to the outside saw
the people in the streets seize up and
begin to shriek in terrible pain their
skin sagged and their bones liquefied
their bodies dropped down to the ground
and coalesced into gurgling wretching
Puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this Abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas an
afterimage burned into the plasma of an
old TV screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden Insanity taking over the
world caused the SCP Foundation to do
some something drastic step out of the
Shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary Foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that Humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage while
one side of the Earth was effectively
doomed the second the process began the
other side had a 12-hour Head Start
before the sun turned its terrible eye
to them sirens went off in the middle of
the night waking people up groggy
rubbing the sleep on their eyes every
television and radio and
internet-enabled device in their home
was playing the same message direct from
the SCP Foundation which now had
effectively commandeered the entire U.S
government along with the rest of the
world it gave them directions to the
nearest Foundation containment site and
told them that if they didn't
immediately comply and find their way to
safety they would experience a terrible
death by sunrise and if you're at all
familiar with human beings you probably
are already predicted that they didn't
just calmly wrap themselves up make
their way to their cars and form an
orderly line to the various Foundation
containment sites located around them it
was in fact total pandemonium as the
solar clock ticked down slowly marking
off the seconds that anyone outside had
left to live the only human beings with
a meaningful Head Start began to go
insane in a number of varied and
interesting ways some who took the
situation seriously and acknowledged
that the sun was indeed going to wipe
out most of humanity simply cracked
under the pressure there were those who
went into totally catatonic States
rocking back and forth in the corner and
refusing to respond to any stimuli some
became erratic and violent with
unpredictable behavior that harmed
themselves and others after all what was
the point in acting normally anymore
when the complete crumbling of human
civilization was imminent and their only
hope was some shadowy organization
they'd never heard of some not heeding
the warning seriously enough enough and
prompted by greed and opportunism try to
take advantage of the situation
financially some smashed Windows of
local stores and looted or broke into
the homes of neighbors who had already
fled in hopes of proloing their property
others were a little more creative
setting up short term Everything Must Go
nighttime fire sales for their brands of
essential oils nootropics and
nutraceuticals claiming all of them had
the power to ward off or cure the new
effects of the sun others completely
denied the possibility that any of this
was real and claimed that the messages
from this so-called SCP Foundation were
actually just a front to take away their
freedoms and trap them in underground
government camps they staunchly refused
to follow any of the safety guidelines
that the SCP Foundation put out claiming
if you try to take away my first
amendment rats you're gonna take away my
second amendment rats while riding
around in their pickup trucks and SUVs
blasting Kid Rocks don't tell me how to
live at ear splitting volumes naturally
they had all melted into screeching
puddles of liquid flash by Sunrise some
were not victims of their own bizarre
choices but were doomed by the sudden
terrible fear and panic of the
circumstances themselves the highways
were gridlocked cars stuck as far as the
eye could see so many had rushed to
escape during the initial wave that
means of Transport soon became choke
points like clogged arteries in a dying
man people do irrational things when
they're scared riots broke out in the
streets fighting killing burning
everyone hoping for some means of meager
control over a situation that had long
been out of any of their hands some were
too far away with not enough time to
close the distance what could they
really do but just sit around and wait
to die the hours marched on as the earth
made its slow turn towards the sun
leaving one decimated half in darkness
and the other a Sitting Duck for its
terrible effects hundreds of thousands
had made their way to the containment
sites and safely got side but still so
many millions were left outside it was a
slaughterhouse one great big Global meat
grinder and every moment that passed the
handle turned and any humans left
outside got just that little bit closer
to the grinding gnashing gears below
site 19 being the largest containment
site on the foundation books also became
Humanity's only Bastion it was the great
hope of escape from the horrors going on
outside the foundation had figured out
so many ways of counteracting deadly
anomalous forces before given enough
time and enough Personnel surely they
could figure out a solution to even this
this was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors those who were melted by the
sudden hostile Sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they'd
been changed in both body and mind what
had once been humans now became terrible
beasts half-melted gelatinous nightmares
that coagulated into even bigger beasts
they got into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation that
they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world they were
something so much more now and they
wanted everyone else to join them in
their Liberation survivors outside the
foundation containment sites were
systematically hunted by these great
masses of altered flesh even though
smart enough to cover every inch of
their bodies with clothes to protect
from the Sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by needy
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the Searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coalesce
into something greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases
the foundation with what remained of
their Manpower and advanced Weaponry did
what they could to repel the attacks but
every single day it got harder
thankfully for the people holed up at
site 19 there was one consolation out
there to help
scp-99 the foundation was at war with
the sun and its terrible disciples and
contrary to many people's beliefs it
takes more than men equipment and
bullets to win a war 999 provided the
essential element that brought it all
together morale hope the will to go on
even when it seemed like all could be
lost after a long day of battling the
fleshy Abominations At The Gates
Foundation guards mobile task force
members and even civilian volunteers
were drained and traumatized by the
horrors that they'd seen once a day was
over 999 would move among the ranks
cuddling up to them warding off the
despair that was easy to set in during
the downswing of a terrible apocalypse
like this without his presence there
would be no hope of fighting that good
fight so many of them would have given
up walked into the Sun and joined the
Monstrous Force they were fighting after
all they seemed happy enough and it
would certainly be easier 999 had become
once again an indispensable asset to the
SCP Foundation the solar betrayal may
not have been the Scarlet King's doing
while as far as our current Intel
suggests anyway but he was playing a
crucial part in saving the world exactly
as predicted 999 didn't fully understand
what was going on outside sometimes why
there seemed to be fewer people as the
weeks went on and why the people there
seemed so sad all the time whenever he
wasn't helping them but he was more than
happy to help whatever the case many of
the humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically pose no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom have lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after your day
broke everyone needed a good
old-fashioned cry however one day while
wandering The Long Dark corridors of
site 19 he saw a different kind of crime
it was a woman with an unfamiliar face
probably one of the rare new refugees
bawling her eyes out to a foundation
senior researcher and an accompanying
guard with an assault rifle hot fat
tears were rolling down her dirty cheeks
her shaking hands clasped in prayer she
was begging the researcher and the guard
to let her go outside she said that her
son was still out there hiding away in
the back room of a bank where she used
to work they got separated she needed to
go back and find him sadly the
researcher and the guard told her that
this was out of the question official
orders stated that anyone outside the
base at this time was to be considered
lost letting her go out there to find
her son would essentially be condemning
her to death no human could go out there
safely but of course
scp-999 isn't by any definition a human
when night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the SCP Foundation might try to
stop it when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and threw the
broken streets there were no bodies of
course it seemed even the dead could be
revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
Miracle but the broken down World
outside site 19 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead
voices 999 had been cross-tested with
scp-682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the world as we had all
known it disappeared an array of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discreetly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and to use those signals like a
homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hidden inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
dried 999 cooed and chirped pleasantly
until the little boy was laughing again
but this momentary Joy was soon
interrupted a great heaving weight
dragged itself down the hall outside
both 999 and the boy could sense its
monstrous presence as it got closer they
could hear all those chattering voices
those poisonous Whispers when it passed
the door they heard it speaking its
voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy turn pretty flowers
on your face feel yourself change and
snooze and mix into us become one with
our army of One it must be so
Little Flower walk into the Sun and be
us 999 and the boy remain silent in the
broom closet for hours as the great
shape patrolled the bank outside
searching for converts for victims at
times it seemed too frightening to even
breathe fearing that would be enough to
make the monster detect them it felt
like an eternity until the monster
eventually did slope off and leave them
in the comforting quiet and darkness of
the closet now they might be free 999
could escort the boy safely back to the
containment site and into the arms of
his terrified mother but when they
opened the door they saw a terrible
sight light in the distance pouring
through the windows in the glass double
doors it wouldn't be safe to go out that
way upon seeing this and putting
together what it meant the boy began to
cry he couldn't take another night in
the closet it was all going to wither
from here until 999 had a wonderful idea
hours later when the foundation's guards
manned the turrets at the entrance of
site 19 waiting for the inevitable
onslaught of the melted flesh creatures
they tensed up seeing a blobbing
gelatinous form slithering towards them
in the distance the guards who'd learned
the hard way from too many lost men that
it was better to be safe than sorry Drew
a bead on the distant shape and prepared
to fire when suddenly their Superior
raced a hand and said wait hold fire is
that 999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 cheaper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
an amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own capacity 999
had given the boys safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
Hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people
scp-999 really was saving the world or
what was left of it anyway oh and of
course if scp-999 had won your hearts
just like it won ours you'd be pleased
to know that you can purchase your own
adorable high quality scp-9999 plushie
at scpswag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cuddle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier oh boy
here we go again scp-00
001 over 30 different bizarre anomalies
claim this number one spot in the
database and in a sense they're all
right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate 001 entries out
there ketter Duty just pray you never
get assigned to it you see when you work
around weirdness you sometimes get a
little weird yourself and nobody deals
with more weirdness than employees of
the SCP Foundation they regularly rub
elbows with everything from Godlike
cicadas to hyper-infectious Supernatural
viruses and as the famous Tom Jones song
goes It's Not Unusual to suddenly take
on anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
Dr Jack Bright is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but but
outside of some famous exceptions the
SCP Foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
trades while on the foundation payroll
you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ketter duty
but what is cutter Duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official cutter Duty
guidelines list a surprisingly vast
number of afflictions these include
chronic anomalous illnesses such as
lycanthropy turning into a werewolf
something called Stevenson syndrome and
the incredibly unpleasant sounding
photonic gastric discharge syndrome you
could also be placed on ketterduty
because you're suffering from the
manifestation of spectral phenomena
including being haunted by Spirits
whether they're there to torment you or
protect you the sudden expression of
anomalous traits in your DNA which is
unsettlingly vague will also land you on
ketterduty as will The Awakening of
powerful magical or psionic abilities
especially ones which could be used in a
potentially offensive manner the
ketterduty assignment which involves
being relocated and forced to work in a
different highly secretive location that
will be discussed soon is framed as a
punishment for the people involved that
way it discourages Foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous
powers on purpose so what exactly is
ketterduty and where does it happen to
reinforce that punishment element method
the foundation has spread lies among
their own Personnel about where the job
takes place often involving being posted
in some of the least desirable
Foundation areas imaginable these
include Point Nemo the area of the ocean
farthest from any place of land on Earth
Pyongyang in North Korea Stonehenge
Roswell lunar area 32 and a number of
foundation waste disposal sites however
the reality of where those on Qatar Duty
end up is even stranger site 100 which
in this particular instance is the true
scp-001 this thumbnail class anomaly is
perhaps the most unique of all
multi-anomaly Foundation containment
sites a bizarre Labyrinth of
non-euclidean geometry that defies true
explanation but will do the best we can
in a sense site 100 is a facility with a
mind of its own it's a sprawling
underground base with a layout that
defies space-time and what's more it
undergoes so-called migration events
every so often it will begin to exhibit
a sense of dimensional instability
before teleporting to a different
location somewhere on Earth currently
the primary entrance to site 100 known
as Alpha entrance is located in the
Southwest United States though all signs
point to another migration event
happening this very year but knowing
where the entrance is will only get you
so far people assigned to Cutter Duty
are sent from the alpha entrance to the
administration sector to be given their
initial breaching at which point the
true Madness begins let's take a look at
a map of site 100 yikes so there are 10
major sectors in site 100 that you
should be aware of entrance Alpha
Administration archives technological
containment biocontainment Sapient
containment Cognito hazardous memetic
and semantic or CMS containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site-100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site site 100 is a
spatial anomaly of truly epic
proportions while the foundation is
aware of the existence of its competent
sectors it's impossible to map out any
meaningful connections between them it
would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without
passageways known as The Roots however
these aren't just mere portals that you
can hop through like the ways in and out
of The Wanderers Library each route
between the sectors is its own complex
environment with its own sets of
protocols and rituals required to safely
travel through it root aleph the bridge
between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic Beach blocked off by an
apparently Limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rocks swim in the
nearby Waters root Beth connecting the
core and sapin containment is a huge and
sprawling fun house Hall of Mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at their starting point in
Sapient containment root Dallas the
bridge that connects conceptual
containment and the core is a massive
ocean that has resisted all attempts by
the foundation to Traverse it rootvav
the bridge between esoteric containment
and conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees Foundation Expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to Traverse
one Expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immediately
teleported back to the starting point
rude Sade connecting Administration to
the CMS sector is a huge Lush Forest on
top of a floating Mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
Forest are non-anomalous flamingos next
we have root pear the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a city
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by
non-hostile humanoid creatures who will
approach Foundation staff traversing
root pay and invite them into their
Apartments offering to partake in
recreational activities with them such
as video games board games or watching
movies the foundation discourages its
staff from accepting any of these offers
while on the job and then there's root
Shin which connects the Sapient and
conceptual containment sector this route
is unique in the sense that it acts as a
power generator for the rest of site 100
as it's filled with hundreds of large
perpetual motion machines producing a
constant 8.7 gigawatts of electricity
these are only some of the many routes
Illustrated on the site 100 diagram as
you've probably gathered by now it's
less like a conventional building and
more like a whole crazy Dimension unto
itself why does the foundation work to
maintain such a crazy place wouldn't it
just be easier to keep it a secret and
contain it like any other anomaly while
side 100 wouldn't be given the scp-001
designation if it wasn't incredibly
important if site 100 was ever
compromised it would lead to an
inevitable k-class end of the world
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ketter class SCP in our universe hence
the nickname ketter2d for those working
at the site in fact an anomaly can even
be classed as a cutter if it isn't given
permission by site 100 the various
sectors of site 100 cover the entire
spectrum of anomalies and each sector is
a massive panoptic structure connected
by networks of glass elevators whenever
a new cutter class SCP is discovered its
name and a brief description of its
anomalous traits will inscribe itself on
one of the walls in its corresponding
sector ever been frustrated when the o5
council refused to sign off on an
upgrade to Cutter class for a clearly
dangerous SCP that poses extreme risk of
containment breach don't blame them it's
simply that site 100 didn't sanction the
change anytime that site 100 sanctions a
new SCP it also undergoes another unique
process it selects an
scp-001-k instance for the new ketter
and creates a connection between them
using access points known as thresholds
think of it as simply opening a
spatially anomalous door between two as
CPS much like a good boy another SCP
vying for the zero 001 slot site 100 has
an intuitive grasp of the Unseen
connections between ketterclass
anomalies and each
scp-001-k instance is a complementary
cutter class that will essentially
cancel out the threat of its other half
site 100 is a containment Matchmaker its
innate ability to use the anomalous to
contain the anomalous is second to none
first it took
scp-3984 an anomalous phenomenon that
seemed to prevent death from happening
to all life forms in order to mitigate
the effects of 3984 site 100 opened a
threshold between it and
scp-2935 also known as odaf an alternate
universe hidden Beyond a limestone
Cavern where all life simultaneously
cease to exist even down to the
bacterial level by opening the threshold
and allowing these two absolute
opposites to mix it seemed to undermine
the effects of both and create a
non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal Life Next
scp-5007 this terrifying underwater
anomaly manifests as a series of
tentacle-like protrusions that snatch
unfortunate creatures that get too close
and assimilate them into its own Mass
site 100 cleverly opened a threshold to
scp-169 a massive underwater anthropod
known as the Leviathan
scp-169 was Tangled Up by the tentacles
but it's too big to be fully consumed or
assimilated and the result is that 5007
is trapped in a perpetually
incapacitated State akin to choking
keeping it contained and stopping it
from going after anyone else let's take
a look at two even more hostile and
dangerous ketter class anomalies matched
up by site 100 first we've got
scp-5501 an old camera from the 1800s
that comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
within reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer
scp-1983 this is a small house that acts
as a portal to a race of tall monsters
with needle-like appendages that leave
the house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
side 100 opened a threshold into the
scp-1983 house and placed the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
Hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 another ketter class dealt
with by scp-100 is SCP pl122 this is a
deadly plot of land in Poland which
decays and corrodes all matter organic
or inorganic placed within its confines
this would be bad enough but as you'll
often find with anomalous plots of
deadly land its area of influences
growing even knowing about it can cause
it to become more powerful but site 100
found its perfect cutter class
counterpart
scp-1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around seven
kilometers an hour much like absolute
death and absolute Life by putting 1262
into SCP pl122 a healthy medium was
found somewhere in between and finally
perhaps the strangest and most creative
match site 100 has ever pulled off
scp-3852 and
scp-2547 3852 is an anonymous corpse
that manifests in small towns sowing
fear and suspicion eventually a local
person is believed to be responsible for
this murder and is lynched in a rage by
the townspeople as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent talking coyote dressed as
a priest side 100 had the truly Galaxy
brain idea to open a threshold and
connect the two as a result whenever the
corpse manifests in the town the dogs
Rampage in and take over at that point
they set up a kind of ridiculous
Kangaroo Court where a jury made up of
people from the town are forced to find
3852's scapegoat innocent if they don't
the dogs will simply hold the town's
water supply hostage until 3852's
anomalous effects pass such an obvious
idea now why didn't the foundation think
of that cutter Duty may not be the most
conventional easy or attractive work but
like everything the foundation does
making sure site 100 can keep doing its
job as a necessary part of keeping our
world safe from anomalous threats now if
you'll excuse us we need to get going
do you know which is the right route out
of here now go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and
scp-001 when day breaks for more on the
mysterious scp-001